Okay, everybody, welcome back to the
computer screen. Welcome to video number
six of the professional trading
masterclass video series. This is going to
be a very long video. The first part of
the video will be covered by myself. And
second part, which is very long, we're
going to be doing a spreadsheet plus an
Excel lesson.
with Christopher Quill. In video six, we
are going to introduce you now to an
accessory to what we've learned so far
relating to bond market leading
indicators, we're going to be looking at
the money supply. But before we do
introduce money supply into our analysis
and framework, what I want to do is just
have a quick
recap and understand how everything fits
together. You know, at this stage, last
couple of videos, we've covered obviously
a lot of information. It's a lot to digest
and take in. And sometimes it's because
there's so many moving parts, it can be
quite difficult to grasp how everything
fits together. So let's, let's look at
this. And what have we covered up to this
point?
in the previous two videos? Well, we
covered government and sovereign bond
markets and the corporate bond markets.
And what did we actually achieve out of
that? What did we get? Well, we've now got
several useful leading indicators for
predicting a number of dynamics that are
important to traders and portfolio
managers.
So what are these dynamics that we're
always trying to predict at any one moment
in time? Well, it's the government and
corporate bond market, first of all, in
terms of liquidity and money flows. And
these dynamics are leading dynamics, okay.
And we are using leading indicators in the
bond market.
So let's look at the bond market to
predict the bond market to predict these
dynamics. What else are we trying to
predict in terms of dynamics? Well, we're
trying to predict stock market liquidity
and also stock market volatility and stock
market direction and possible returns.
Why? Because we want to form a
macroeconomic view, which essentially
forms our portfolio.
We want to look at our portfolio bias. So
government and corporate bond market
liquidity and money flows, stock market
liquidity and volatility. And stock market
direction and possible returns are all
leading dynamics that we are trying to
predict. What are they leading? They are
leading corporate earnings growth. So the
corporate earnings output.
We want to look at the corporate earnings
outlook. That's our own expectation of the
future growth of corporate earnings and
leading economic growth. So leading GDP.
So both stock market corporate earnings
and GDP growth are both lagging dynamics.
dynamics. Now, as we are long-short equity
portfolio managers, we are located in the
stock
market. We are not necessarily taking
positions in bond market instruments. We
are taking
positions in the stock market, and we are
expressing our portfolio bias via the
stock
market and stocks. So, what we really care
about here is stock market liquidity and
volatility
and stock market direction and possible
returns. From the bond market, we get our
leading indicators
that predict these dynamics. We get
leading indicators to predict dynamics
that are leading
corporate earnings and GDP growth. What
were they? Well, we know what they are.
Real
interest rates, the yield curve, that's in
the government bond market, and investment
grade,
high yield or junk spreads over the
10-year, that's in the corporate bond
market. And we
combine these leading indicators with a
leading indicator in the stock market,
which is stock
market volatility, the S&P 500 fix, which
was covered in the IPLT video series. Now,
we also
mentioned and covered Fed outlook and
policy. So, what the Federal Reserve is
doing. We discussed
and covered that these leading indicators,
they are always being monitored by the
Federal Reserve
as indicators of expected economic growth.
The Fed itself has a self-mandated target
for annual
inflation and unemployment in the US
economy. This is what's called the dual
mandate. And at the time of
writing, which is 2021, or at the time of
recording, the Fed's official target for
inflation is 2% with an
expected real GDP growth rate of 3.3% in
2022 and 2.2% in 2023. Now, we also
learned that the Fed
interventionally intervenes in the money
markets to manipulate the supply of funds
via both conventional
and non-conventional methods. And up to
this point, the conventional method that
we've covered is via
interest rates. So, via the interest rate
mechanism, the Fed intervenes in the money
markets to manipulate the
supply of funds via interest rates. But
they also do this via money supply, which
is considered a conventional policy from
the Fed.
So, the conventional monetary policy tools
that the Fed uses to manipulate the supply
of funds is interest rates and the money
supply.
Non-conventional means, so
non-conventional tools that the Fed uses,
would be things like asset purchase
programs. Now, both conventional and
non-conventional tools that the Fed uses
would be things like asset purchase
programs.
Non-conventional means, so
non-conventional tools that the Fed uses.
What are they using for? Well, it's
obviously to intervene in the money
markets to manipulate liquidity, but the
reason for this is to manage inflation and
economic growth.
Non-conventional means, so at this stage,
non-conventional means, the money supply.
we bring in the money supply as a
conventional tool.
And we have to understand the money supply
as a conventional tool used by the Fed.
But what we also do is, is we add the
Fed's actions, what the Fed is doing with
their policy.
We add the Fed actions into our dynamics
predictor list.
So, we add it to the predictor list, where
we had previously government and corporate
bond liquidity and money flows,
stock market liquidity and volatility,
direction and possible returns of the
stock market.
We add the Federal Reserve policy and
outlook to our dynamics predictor list.
Why? Because the Fed is looking at what we
look at.
Now, how the Fed behaves with these tools
can both be leading and lagging as a
dynamic.
Why? Because the Fed, when they're looking
at the same stuff we're looking at, they
can strike preemptively.
They can take measures very quickly and
timely in order to prevent economic
issues.
Okay?
Or, they can actually sit back and they
can react later to economic situations.
So, what would be an example of the Fed
having a preemptive policy response?
Well, if they are looking at, for example,
in the government and corporate bond
markets, and they're seeing the beginning
of some stresses appearing,
what they may do is use either
conventional or non-conventional tools to
actually prevent further stresses
occurring.
That would be a very quick and timely
response.
What would be an example of a lagging or
reactive policy measure?
Well, that could be, for example, on the
flip side.
So, let's say we've had a very, very long
period of strong economic growth.
We've been in a very long expansionary
phase with high levels of inflation, for
example.
Well, a Fed lagging response could be to
actually leave it a very long time and
allow the expansion to keep going.
And keep interest rates low, keep money
supply ticking over and high, and not
raise interest rates in response to
inflation, for example, potentially
getting out of control.
So, they may be happy to sit back and
allow inflation and economic growth to
continue for a long time and not have a
policy response of higher interest rates,
but allow higher interest rate policy to
lag by a fairly long period of time.
Another example of lagging or reactive
policy from the Fed may be in response to
some sort of exogenous shock.
So, for example, like COVID in 2020, when
we have an immediate liquidity crisis that
was pretty much unforeseen or unexpected.
And the Fed comes in with both
conventional and non-conventional means
and takes huge action in reaction to the
exogenous event.
So, of course, we as traders and portfolio
managers are always trying to stay on top
via our leading indicators.
We are always trying to stay on top of
both government and corporate bond
liquidity and money flows,
on top of stock market liquidity, stock
market volatility, and the direction and
possible returns of the stock market.
We are always trying to stay on top of the
stock market.
But we also have to introduce the dynamic
in the predictor list of the Fed because
they are looking at the same stuff we are
looking at,
and they could enact a policy response
that's either very timely and leading, so
pre-emptive, or non-timely and lagging,
reactive.
So, it is a dynamic that we have to be on
top of.
We must be on top of Fed policy and
outlook, and also their intentions for
both conventional and non-conventional
monetary policy.
At an absolute minimum, we have to be on
top of a number of things.
So, the official interest rate.
Money supply growth.
This is where money supply now fits in.
Money supply is a conventional monetary
tool used by the Fed.
We have to be on top of what the Fed's
target inflation rate is, what the Fed is
expecting GDP growth to be going forward.
We have to be on top of the FOMC, the
Federal Open Market Committee meetings
calendar for setting interest rates.
These are the Fed meetings that are held
eight times a year to decide on the level
of interest rates.
We also need to be on top of Fed language
for expected interest rate moves in the
future.
The bond market reacts to that.
The minutes of these meetings, of the Fed
meetings, are released three weeks after
interest rate policy decisions,
and we need to be on top of the press
conferences.
So, this is interest rates and
conventional monetary policy outlook.
We also have to be on top of the Fed's
non-conventional policy.
So, the size and speed of asset purchase
programs, and also the language for
expected future changes in those asset
purchase programs.
These are non-conventional monetary policy
tools.
So, at a minimum, we have to be on top of
these things.
The leading indicators and the dynamics
that we're trying to predict with those
leading indicators,
they are being watched by the Fed as well.
And Fed policy can change our view on the
leading indicators, and therefore, our
view on the dynamic predictors.
If, for example, we are using our leading
indicators to predict stock market
direction and possible returns,
and from our leading indicators, we
become, for example, very bearish on the
stock market,
and we think to ourselves, we need to have
a short portfolio bias.
Well, guess what?
The Fed is looking at the same things too.
And a Fed policy response that's leading,
so preemptive, a timely preemptive
response can actually change those
dynamics very quickly.
So, we have to be on top of these things
very obviously as a dynamic.
And on the flip side, if we're looking at
our leading indicators, and we're
extremely bullish, we have a net long
portfolio bias in our trading portfolio.
And the market, the stock market,
everything seems really good.
Everything seems really strong.
We're getting the right direction of
positive, and the returns in the markets
are strong.
So, what happens if we get overly bullish,
and then the Fed has some sort of reactive
or even preemptive response to that,
where inflation might be getting too high,
expectations of economic growth are
getting overheated or out of control,
and the Fed has some sort of combination
of conventional and non-conventional
policy response.
Well, our dynamic is going to change,
okay?
The leading indicators can be affected by
that very quickly.
The predictor list can change very
quickly.
And the Fed is responsible for those
changes.
So, you know, in all scenarios here, at
any one moment in time, we have to be on
top of what the Fed is doing.
But don't worry, there's lots of resources
and links that we can utilize to stay on
top of this stuff.
If you go to the downloads area underneath
this video, you'll see a PDF that we've
put together with a whole bunch of
resources and links to help you out in the
future in staying on top of Fed, Outlook
and Policy.
Just as a reminder and a visual here, if
you think back to the beginning of the
video series,
when we were looking at the overall
framework and understanding what we're
trying to do here in terms of predicting
GDP,
how the S&P 500, the stock market leads
corporate earnings and leads GDP.
Just a reminder as a visual of what we're
trying to achieve here.
So it's better for you or helpful for you
to understand how everything fits in.
So we're obviously using our leading
indicators to predict stock market
liquidity and volatility direction and
possible returns.
And they are leading the lagging
indicators, which are economic growth, the
stock market corporate earnings that are
reported every quarter.
So the same as GDP, which is reported
every quarter.
But these two indicators are lagging and
also inflation is lagging as well.
Those indicators are telling you what
happened in the past, but the stock market
trades every day.
Okay.
So we are utilizing the stock market and
stocks to predict the direction and
possible returns of the stock market that
are leading economic growth and corporate
earnings by around six months.
From our view of the leading indicators
and also from Fed policy and outlook.
From this, we are achieving our portfolio
bias of either being net long, net short
or neutral in our portfolio.
So now that we've got a better
understanding of how everything fits in,
in terms of our list of dynamic predictors
and also leading indicators.
And where, for example, Fed policy and
outlook fits in, we can now add our second
conventional monetary policy tool, M2
money supply.
So we're bringing in money supply as a
leading indicator, but more defined as an
accessory leading indicator alongside our
leading indicators that we've looked at so
far.
So real interest rates in the yield curve
in the government bond markets, investment
grade and high yields or junk spreads over
the 10 year.
So in the corporate bond markets and the
S&P 500 VIX index, which was in the IPRT
video series for predicting stock market
volatility.
So M2 money supply we're bringing in now
as an accessory leading indicator, and
really it's an accessory leading indicator
because over the years, money supply
growth, which is the important factor that
we're looking at.
We're looking at money supply growth and
the changing dynamic of the monetary
mechanism and specifically the velocity of
money.
So how quickly money makes its way through
the economy.
That's changed in terms of strength and
predictability with leading economic
growth over time.
Okay.
So it's quite difficult to draw very
meaningful conclusions in terms of
correlations between money supply growth
and economic growth and stock market.
It's a very, very good way of looking at
money supply growth in that it is a
conventional Federal Reserve monetary
policy tool that is still utilised very
actively by the Fed and the best way to
understand it is to think of it in terms
of liquidity and the intentions of the
Federal Reserve.
So we can use money supply growth, M2
money supply growth as if you like a
confirmation indicator, even though it's
really defined as a leading indicator in
that money supply does lead economic
growth to varying degrees throughout
history.
So as traders as traders and PMs, what we
want to be doing is using it as an
accessory, as a confirmation indicator.
So a confirming leading indicator of Fed
policy.
So for example, in a period of expansion,
where Fed policy in our other leading
indicator space is in an easing bias,
where we have lower interest rates, short
end of the economy.
We have lower interest rates, short end of
the yield curve is being manipulated in
some way by a conventional or
non-conventional means.
So for example, a normal yield curve
exists, the corporate bond market is
looking healthy, but we look at, for
example, M2 money supply, and we see the
Fed reducing money supply.
This would be at odds to what we're seeing
in the government and corporate bond
markets, and this might raise some
questions from traders and PMs that the
Fed may actually be tapering.
Now, look at it on the other side, on the
flip side, what would happen, for example,
if we were in an expansionary phase, and
we saw the Fed starting to print more
money in terms of M2 money supply growth.
So we're starting to look at M2 money
supply growth.
So we're not trying to look at M2 money
supply growth here and trying to correlate
it exactly with a certain level of GDP
growth or stock market returns.
What we're doing here, we're using it as a
confirmation leading indicator of Fed
policy and whether we see what's going on
in the bond market is consistent with M2
money supply growth.
So are the Fed's actions consistent or are
they potentially changing?
Now, Chris Quill is going to teach you all
about M2 money supply growth in a
spreadsheet class that's coming up very
soon.
But let's understand the definition of
money supply here.
And there's various definitions of money.
There's M1 and there's M2 definition of
money.
M1 as a definition only includes cash and
checking deposits.
M2 definition of money is a calculation
that includes M1, so all the elements of
M1, cash and checking deposits, as well as
what we call in financial markets, NIA
money.
NIA money refers to savings deposits,
money market securities, mutual funds and
other time deposits.
It's a measure of the money supply that
includes both cash and checking deposits,
so M1 and NIA money, which is anything
that's easily convertible into cash.
Okay.
M2 is therefore a broader measure of the
money stock and the M1 money supply.
Okay.
M2 and M2 growth is an accessory leading
indicator to future inflation and
liquidity in the economy.
And as a target of central bank monetary
policy.
So, what are we doing as traders and PMs?
We are looking at money supply growth,
utilizing the M2 definition of cash and
checking deposits, M1, plus NIA money as
an accessory leading indicator to future
inflation.
In the economy and liquidity in both the
economy and financial markets.
And of course, as a tool that's used by
the Federal Reserve, who are using it as a
tool to manipulate liquidity and inflation
in the economy.
And from that, we are drawing conclusions
of either confirmation or denial of what's
occurring in bond markets when we're
looking at our other leading indicators
and Fed policy in both the government and
corporate bond markets.
Now, the data set for the M2 money stock
is a big data set.
It goes back many years, and it's very
useful.
Very useful in looking at money supply
growth over time and understanding what is
normal and what is abnormal.
What we've got in the downloads area is a
spreadsheet titled US M2 money supply
template.
And what this is, is a template of M2
money supply growth.
And the reason we calculate this is to
assess money supply growth throughout time
and understand what is normal money supply
growth and what is abnormal.
Now, as a student of the PTM video series,
generally in financial markets, the method
that we use is a distribution of returns
analysis, which viewers of the IPLT video
series will have seen before.
And when we looked at using the method to
determine volatility in various asset
classes, as a student of PTM and of
financial markets in general, you have to
practice using the distribution of returns
analysis because it can be applied to many
situations in financial markets.
And in this situation, we can apply
exactly the same method to measuring M2
money supply growth.
So analyzing Fed actions to stimulate
liquidity, inflation and GDP growth in the
money market, OK, in the money market
utilizing M2 money supply.
So we download the data.
We download the M2 money supply data
through a statistical analysis.
We analyze M2 money supply growth.
And from that, we can infer Federal
Reserve actions to stimulate liquidity,
inflation and GDP growth.
So Chris Quill is going to show you now
how to do this distribution of returns
analysis for the M2 money supply data.
Chris will apply that same method that we
used in the IPLT video series on US M2
data.
And this video is pretty long, guys.
He goes into great detail of how to do
this at every step.
Chris will be with us throughout the video
series doing a lot of spreadsheet classes.
And yeah, just pay attention and practice
these methods.
At first, it will be time consuming.
It will be new.
It might be a little difficult and tricky
to memorize and internalize all of the
steps and processes that you need to go
through to do this.
But don't worry.
Over time, with a lot of practice, you'll
get much, much quicker and more efficient
at doing this.
And don't forget, the spreadsheet in the
downloads area is a template.
So you can actually just learn the
template, understand the dynamics of how
it works, and then update the template
regularly when data comes out.
So let's go over to Chris now.
And I'll see you in the next video.
Hi, guys.
Welcome to your first spreadsheet class of
this course.
My name is Chris Quill, and I'm the
Institute's Quantitative Analyst.
Throughout this course, you're going to be
seeing me crop up occasionally to teach
you some quantitative methods that are
important to understand when it comes to
trading and managing your own portfolios.
We're always going to be using Excel for
our analysis.
So there's no requirement for any
programming knowledge or anything like
that.
And for your reference, I'm going to be
using Excel 2016 throughout.
So depending on the version of Excel that
you have, the layout and the processes
that you need to use might be very
slightly different, although that is
unlikely.
But if you do get stuck, then you can just
use Google to find the answer to the
differences that you see in certain
processes between your version of Excel
and the 2016 version that I have.
Okay.
So in this video, I'm going to show you
how to analyze money supply data for the
US.
And this spreadsheet that you guys see in
front of you now is where we're headed.
Basically, you're going to learn how to
build something like this yourselves.
And this spreadsheet basically analyzes M2
money supply growth for the US.
Now, when it comes to money supply, it can
be a little bit complicated to use as a
leading indicator, but we're going to keep
it simple as much as possible and stick to
some basic economic principles when going
through our assessment.
And if you look at money supply
historically, money supply growth, it's
had a pretty dynamic relationship with GDP
in the stock market.
So it's not necessarily easy to draw
conclusions about correlations or anything
like that.
And the reason for that is basically that
things like market mechanisms and the
velocity of money has changed over time.
The velocity of money being, you know, how
quickly money circulates around the
economy and how effectively it's used.
That being said, it is important that you
guys understand that money supply is one
of the tools used by the Fed to stimulate
the economy and markets.
And the best way to think about that is in
terms of liquidity.
So when markets in the economy are liquid
or expected liquidity decreases, the Fed
tries to step in to plug the void by
increasing money supply growth.
So we can use interest rates, which you
guys have been through in previous videos
and the price of money as leading
indicators that tell you about future
economic expectations.
And we can combine that with M2 money
supply as an accessory gauge to understand
Fed expectations or reactions regarding
liquidity.
Realistically, what we're most concerned
with here is the level of M2 prints on a
month to month basis and trying to
understand whether they're within what we
would call a normal range or not.
Particularly, we're concerned about the
higher end.
And you'll understand more about this as I
go through the video.
But if you see high M2 prints, it's a
signal that the Fed is trying to stimulate
the economy and markets through increases
in liquidity.
And it needs to prompt questions for you
guys such as, you know, does this confirm
what I'm seeing across money markets and
other leading indicators?
And if not, what is the Fed seeing that
I'm not?
So the analysis we're going to do in this
video is similar to that which you'll be
familiar with from the IPLT series.
And it involves analyzing the distribution
of a data set.
Now, in the introduction to professional
level trading masterclass, we did this for
various financial assets to understand
risk, opportunity and volatility on a
historical basis.
Here, what we're going to do is carry out
something similar for M2 money supply data
in order to understand and look out for
abnormal changes in the data.
For those of you guys who have done the
IPLT course already, you've got a bit of a
head start here, but there will be plenty
of new concepts introduced in this video
as well.
For the rest of you that haven't, I
strongly recommend going through that
process in the introduction to
professional level trading masterclass
course.
Not only does the IPLT act as a solid
foundation for everything we cover in this
video series, but particularly with the
distribution of returns videos,
it's very important for you to understand
how and why you should carry out that
analysis for financial assets because it
sets the scene for your entire trading
process.
As a brief outline of what we're going to
cover in this video.
Basically, I'm going to show you how to
gather M2 money supply data for the US and
build out an analysis for that data in
Excel like you can see here.
We'll look at how to define and identify
what constitutes abnormal growth in the
money supply and draw some conclusions as
to what that means, some of which I've
already touched on.
Finally, I'll show you a template
spreadsheet which is accessible in the
downloads area for this video.
That's actually what we're looking at here
at the moment.
And that will save you a lot of time in
Excel since it updates all the analysis
automatically whenever you add in new
data.
That being said, it's still very important
that you guys know how to do all of this
from scratch so that you understand how
all the calculations work,
what they're useful for and what their
limitations are.
So we've got a lot to cover in this video.
Get yourselves a coffee, strap in and
let's get started.
Now with any data analysis problem, the
first stage is always outlining our aim,
figuring out what data we need and then
getting hold of that data.
So our aim here is to analyze changes in
the US M2 money supply on the basis that
from our economic understanding,
we think large increases are aimed at
stimulating the economy and financial
markets through a provision of liquidity.
whether that be on a preemptive basis or
through reactive decisions from the Fed.
We want to be able to see when these
increases happen and calculate what
constitutes large or abnormal changes.
So the data we're going to be using for
this analysis is nominal seasonally
adjusted monthly M2 money supply data from
the Federal Reserve,
which includes cash, checking deposits and
other liquid, easily convertible assets.
To find this data, we just need to
navigate to the Federal Reserve Economic
Database website.
So in my web browser here, I've just
navigated to the URL fred.stliviefed.org.
That is the Federal Reserve Economic
Database website.
And from here, we can just search for
whatever we want in this search bar to
find the data that we need.
So I'm just going to put in this search
bar M2 and then click the search icon on
the right hand side.
You can also press enter. And once you do
that, the website will return a list of
data series that are relevant to your
search term.
You can see from the third option here,
we've got M2 money stock.
That's billions of dollars measured in
billions of dollars.
It's weekly and non seasonally adjusted,
and it goes back to 1980.
You'll also see a link below that option
for two other formats of this data series.
So if we click on that, we can see that
there's two monthly series available here
again in billions of dollars.
One is seasonally adjusted and one is not,
and they both go back to 1959.
So there's two reasons that we are going
to pick monthly seasonally adjusted data
as opposed to, you know, weekly non
seasonally adjusted data here.
And that's firstly and most importantly,
because it's a lot harder to pick out what
constitutes abnormal moves when the data
isn't seasonally adjusted.
So in this case, we need the monthly data
for that.
We could work around that issue with
weekly data if we applied seasonal
adjustments ourselves, but frankly, that
isn't as easy as it sounds.
And it's beyond the scope of what you guys
need to understand and learn in this
video.
So that's why the first reason why the
monthly series makes sense.
The second one is that we've got a lot
longer data series to take advantage of
here.
It goes back to 1959.
So we've got more data to look at and
understand what makes a move, a certain
percentage change in the data abnormal or
not.
So we can just click on that link for the
monthly seasonally adjusted data.
It then takes us to a new page for that
data series.
And you can see it's plotted on a chart
here and you can edit the chart or edit
the length of the series.
But by default, it's going to show you the
entire history.
And we don't want to make any clever
changes to this data.
We just want to download the series as is.
So we can just go to the download button
at the top right hand side there.
Click that and download this data to
Excel.
What you'll do then or what the website
does then is downloads this data to your
PC in Excel format.
You can see on my screen here that's
created a link to this Excel sheet that
it's downloaded in the bottom left.
I'm using Google Chrome as my web browser
on a Windows PC.
So that's just the way that I can quickly
open links to newly downloaded files.
For you guys, it might be different.
It might be in your downloads folder or
whatever.
It doesn't really matter.
You just need to navigate to that file and
open it.
When you open the file, you might see a
protected view warning at the top in a
yellow bar.
You can just ignore that and click on
enable editing.
And if we take a look at the data that
we've got here, what you can see is we've
got dates in ascending order in column A.
So running down the column and we've got
the corresponding monthly M2 values in
column B to all of the dates that we
observe in column A.
Okay, so now we have this M2 data, we can
tidy up the spreadsheet a little bit by
deleting unnecessary cells, renaming our
columns and also adjusting the format of
our dates.
What I'm going to start with is renaming
our column for our M2 monthly data.
You can see at the moment in cell B11, we
have a title here that is M2SL.
That is pretty meaningless to us at the
moment.
What I think is a much better title is the
one that we see in cell B8.
So what I'm going to do is copy this title
from cell B8 down to cell B11.
To do that, you can either select the cell
and then right click within the selection
and go to copy and then do the same for
pasting it into cell B11.
Or you can just select cell B8, press Ctrl
C on the keyboard as I've just done there
and then select B11 and press Ctrl V on
the keyboard.
Okay, so now we've got a suitable date for
our M2 monthly data that we can see in
cell B11 there.
What I now want to do is delete all of the
rows from row 1 to 10 because they're
pretty unnecessary for us.
We just want our column titles and all the
data below.
So basically everything we see in row 11
and beyond.
So to delete the top 10 rows, I'm just
going to left click and drag over the row
numbers on the left hand side from row 1
to row 10.
And then right click in that selection and
go to delete and that will delete all of
those rows.
Okay, so now there's a couple more things
I want to do.
First of all, I want to make our column
titles bold.
So I'm going to click and drag, left click
and drag over cells A1 and B1, which are
the cells for our column titles.
And make these bold by pressing Ctrl B on
the keyboard.
You can also do this by navigating to the
home tab on the ribbon and just clicking
on this bold button here.
I just find the keyboard shortcuts a
little bit easier and they'll be useful
for you guys to learn as well.
Let's look at all of our dates in column A
for a moment.
And we can see that all of these dates are
a little bit ambiguous, probably depending
on where you're based in the world,
because people read these date formats
slightly differently.
Sometimes they'll read this as the year
followed by the month, then the day.
followed by the day and then the month.
So to clear up any ambiguity, I'm going to
change the formats of all the dates that
we see in column A.
And I'm going to do that by left clicking
the column letter at the top.
So column A and then right clicking in
that selection and going to format cells.
So we're going to format all of the dates
that we observe in column A here.
So in this format cells dialog box, I'm
going to go to custom as a category and
then overwrite the type as general
overwrite it instead with the following
format.
DD hyphen or dash MMM dash YY.
And when I press OK, you'll see what that
does to the date formats in that column.
We've now quite clearly got the day
followed by the month, followed by the
year.
And we can see from these observations
that the data is on a monthly basis and
it's observed on the first of every month.
Now, in actual fact, if you read about the
monthly M2 data that you download from the
Federal Reserve Economic Database,
despite this saying this is from the first
of each month, the actual corresponding
data is an average over that entire month.
So if we take the first data that we have
here, so what we can read here is the
first of January 1959.
This is our M2 money stock monthly season.
The adjusted value in billions of dollars
is 286.6.
In actual fact, that is the average value
over the entire month of January in 1959.
It doesn't really affect things for our
analysis, but I just wanted to point that
out to you guys.
If you want to quickly navigate to the
bottom of the spreadsheet just to make
sure that, you know, your formatting
changes have worked or anything like that.
A quick shortcut to do that is just to
press control down on the keyboard.
That will take you to the end of the data
series in whatever column you're in.
So the bottom of the data series, you can,
of course, also use the scroll bar on the
right hand side as well.
And you can use the scroll bar going from
left to right here as well.
If you want to scroll to the top or the
right hand side of the left hand side very
quickly, as I said, a shortcut is using
control and the arrow keys.
So if I want to go back to the top, I can
just press control and up on the keyboard.
A final change that I want to make to our
headings here is just to wrap the text.
At the moment, you can see in cell B1 our
column heading is quite long.
So it goes outside the bounds of that
cell.
I just want to wrap this text so that
instead of going outside the bounds of the
cell, it just goes down rows and stays
within the cell borders.
I'll show you what I mean in a second.
So let me select, left click and select
cells A1 and B1.
And then within the home tab, click on
wrap text.
And you can see when I do that, it
basically wraps all the text onto
different lines within the confines of a
certain cell.
Okay, now we've made some changes.
I want to make sure that this file is
saved somewhere on my PC so that I can
access this analysis whenever I wish.
So I'm just going to go to file, save as
and browse, and then just browse a folder
on my PC that makes sense to save this
file into.
Okay, so this will be different for you
guys, but I'm just going to put it in this
folder here.
I suggest you make sure that you save the
file type as an XLSX, Excel workbook, and
you know, make it a sensible file name.
So I'm just going to put in USM2 analysis
here and then click save and that will
save the file into that folder.
Finally, now, before we move on to the
next section, let's just quickly rename
this worksheet.
At the moment, you can see this worksheet
is called Fred Graph.
Let's just right click on that sheet name
down here and go to rename and then just
type over with something more sensible.
So I'm going to rename this from Fred
Graph to M2 distribution.
So that will be our new sheet name for
this worksheet that we're in right now.
Let's pause now for a moment and take a
look at this data that we have in a line
chart.
The easiest way to do that is to select
the column of data that we want to plot.
So column B in this instance, and then go
to insert on the ribbon and then choose a
2D line chart from this option here.
And we can choose the top left 2D line
chart option.
And you can see when we do that, that that
creates a chart, plots a line with the
data that we selected and automatically
gives that chart a title equal to whatever
we set the column heading to.
So the value that we've entered into cell
B1 in this case.
Let's tidy up this chart a little bit
though, because at the moment you can see
on the X axis that we've just got a
sequence of numbers rather than the
associated dates for this monthly M2 data.
To change that, we just right click within
this chart selection and go to select
data.
And you'll see then that we have a select
data source dialog box appear.
And we just want to edit the horizontal or
category axis label.
So we can click on this edit button here.
And then in this new dialog box, we just
select all of our dates from cell A2, the
first observation date down to the end of
the data set.
Now, the easiest way to do that is select
cell A2 there and then press Ctrl Shift
and down.
So Ctrl plus Shift plus down on the
keyboard.
And that will automatically select all of
the cells down to the bottom of the data
series in that column.
So all of our dates.
And then we can press OK.
Another way to do that, by the way, is
just left clicking and dragging down that
whole column as well.
You can do that equally if you don't
remember the keyboard shortcut.
But these keyboard shortcuts, as I said,
will save you a lot of time if you do
remember them.
So press OK there and OK again.
And we can scroll back to the top of the
spreadsheet.
And you'll see now that we've got
corresponding dates for all of our monthly
M2 values there.
So that chart captures all of the data
down to row 746.
That's all the data that we selected.
If you wanted the chart to capture new
data that you'll be inputting into the
spreadsheet, then you'd need to change the
cell references so that they capture data
a lot further down the spreadsheet.
And I'm not going to cover how to do that
just here.
But this is something that you will see in
the spreadsheet template that I show you
later in the video and also that you've
got access to in the downloads area.
Now, if you want to move the chart, it's
very simple.
All you need to do is left click on the
chart area and drag that chart around the
sheet as you wish.
And equally, if you want to resize the
chart with the chart area selected, you'll
see some nodes appearing around the edges
and you can click and drag any of those
nodes outwards or inwards to resize the
chart.
If you want to reduce or increase text
sizes of the axis titles or chart title,
then you just need to left click on
whatever element you want and then go to
the home tab and either increase or
decrease the text size to whatever you
want.
So I'm going to do that for the title text
just now.
Just reduce that text size a little bit.
Other aesthetic changes that you can make
are things like altering the color of the
chart area or any text element for that
matter, as well as the style and color of
the data line that you have in the chart.
And to change the color of these various
chart elements, you just need to left
click the chart element that you wish and
use the fill color or text color buttons
on the chart.
So for example, I can change the chart
color to dark blue by selecting the entire
chart area and then selecting a dark blue
color in the home tab in the fill color
option on the home tab.
And we can then change all of the text in
the chart to white because now obviously
we can't see the text as easily if it
stays in a dark color.
So I'll do that just now quickly.
Probably the easiest way to remember how
to make any changes like this is knowing
that you can just select the chart and go
to format on the ribbon.
From there you can then select any element
of the chart that you want and use the
options available to you on the ribbon to
make changes.
So for example, I'll quickly just make two
more changes.
Now I'm going to make the grid lines dark
blue.
So I'm selecting the grid lines here and
then changing the color to dark blue and
then I'll change the data line to a light
yellow.
So I'm just selecting the data line that
we have for our M2 monthly data and
changing that to a light yellow color.
Okay, so we took a bit of a detour there,
but I think it's good to show you guys the
flexibility of Excel in its ability to
present data.
So hopefully you get the idea there.
Let's actually consider the data that
we're looking at now from the chart.
You can see that the M2 money supply
increases fairly consistently over time as
you'd expect with a growing economy and
inflation.
What we want to know though is what the
rate of change of this money supply is
over shorter periods such as monthly and
yearly intervals.
Since that's going to give us an insight
into the expansionary pressures being
applied by the central bank at any time.
So let's continue by calculating monthly
and yearly percentage rates of change to
M2 money supply.
What we're going to do in column C is
calculate our M2 month on month percentage
change values.
And in column D, we're going to calculate
our year on year percentage change values
for M2.
Okay, so in cell C1, I'm just going to
title this column M2 MOM%.
That stands for month on month percentage
change for M2.
In cell D1, I'm going to title column D
with M2 YOY year on year percentage
change.
Okay, so there are column titles.
Next, we want to run our calculations.
So we're just going to calculate for every
value that we see in column B for our M2
money stock.
The percentage change from the previous
value on a month on month basis in column
C.
So I'm going to start in cell C3.
Whenever we type a formula in Excel, it
always starts with equals.
So I'm going to type equals, then
reference the February 59 value for M2.
Divide that by the January 59 value for M2
and minus one.
And that is a formula that will calculate
the percentage change between January 59
and February 59 for M2 money stock.
Okay, you might have seen that written in
a slightly different format before.
For example, you can also in brackets
write it in this form.
So the February value minus the January
value divided by the January value.
Okay, it's the same thing.
So I'll stick to the one that I wrote
previously B3 divided by B2 minus one.
Okay, when I press enter there that
calculates the month on month percentage
change in M2 from February from January 59
to February 59.
And what we're then going to do is
basically copy that formula down on a
relative basis.
So it references the different cells that
it needs to as we copy it down all the way
to the bottom of the data series.
And the easiest way to do that in Excel is
clicking on the formula cell that we've
just calculated and then double clicking
in the bottom right hand corner of that
cell selection, the little green square.
And when we double click that, you'll see
that it basically very quickly copies down
the formulas appropriately to the end of
the data series.
We can check the formulas quite easily.
If we go to the bottom of the data series
and just double click into this final cell
here, cell C746, you'll see that it's
still using the right formula to calculate
month on month percentage change.
So in this case, it's calculating the
percentage change between December 2020
and January 2021.
Okay, so that's our month on month
percentage data done for year on year.
It's almost exactly the same.
It's just we're changing the cell
references about.
So bearing in mind here, our first data
point is in January 59.
Okay, so our first year on year percentage
change that we can calculate would be in
January 1960.
So that would be in this corresponding
cell here, D14.
So I'm going to start this off with an
equal sign.
So it's another formula and we're just
going to calculate the percentage change
between the value we see for M2 on January
1960 divided by the value we see for
January 1959 minus one.
Okay, that's our year on year percentage
change.
And we can copy that formula down in
exactly the same way to the end of the
sheet and we can check it and see that
it's still referencing the right cells.
Okay, let's go back to the top of the
spreadsheet now.
And we'll just make these column titles
bold.
So I'm selecting cells C1 and D1 and just
pressing Ctrl B to make those titles bold.
And then I'm going to select the entirety
of columns C and D and format all the
values, the numbers that we see in these
columns to percentages to two decimal
places.
Because at the moment they're all in
decimal formats.
So I'm left clicking and dragging over the
column letters C and D to select the
entire columns, right clicking in the
selection, going to format cells.
In this dialog box, we're going to click
on percentage category and leave the
decimal places to two decimal places.
Okay, and press okay here.
And then you'll see that all of those
decimals have been reformatted to display
themselves as percentages.
What we can also do now is just very
quickly change the width of these columns
because they are unnecessarily wide at the
moment.
Quite a quick way to do that is just by
clicking, left clicking and dragging the
intersection between columns to make them
wider or narrower.
So we'll just do that for those two
columns, make them both a little bit
narrow or narrower.
And that tidies up our sheet a little bit.
Okay, so now we've got some monthly and
yearly rates of change data calculated in
columns C and D.
Let's compute some statistics to describe
those columns of data and we'll understand
what the data looks like.
And we're going to start with the month on
month change column.
And the easiest way to compute descriptive
statistics quickly in Excel is to use its
data analysis tool located in the data tab
on the ribbon.
So I'm just going to go up to data on the
ribbon here and then go across to data
analysis on the right hand side.
Now, for some of you, this button might
not appear there automatically.
So you'll have to kind of install this
analysis tool pack yourself.
I'll show you very quickly how to do that.
Now you just go to file options add-ins.
And then where it says manage Excel
add-ins down here, you click go.
And you just need to make sure that you've
got these two checkboxes ticked here
analysis tool pack and analysis tool pack
VBA and press OK.
Once you've done that, you should see data
analysis.
The data analysis button appear on the
right hand side of the ribbon within the
data tab.
And you can then use that to calculate
descriptive statistics as follows.
So if we click on that button, you'll see
a dialog box that appears, a data analysis
dialog box, which gives us a number of
different options.
We're going to choose the descriptive
statistics analysis tool and press OK.
What we're then going to do is choose the
range of data that we want to calculate
descriptive statistics for.
Now, remember, I said this is going to be
for our month on month change data.
So what I'm going to do here is basically
select cell C2 within this input range box
and then press control shift and down on
the keyboard to select all of the data in
that column.
So I actually had to press control shift
and down twice there to get to the end of
the data.
And you can see that it's now put in the
input range of C2 to C746.
That's all the data that we need.
We want to then click and select our
output range.
Our output range is just going to be a
cell that we select in this sheet.
I'm going to scroll back to the top of the
sheet and I'm going to select cell G2 here
as our output range.
So our descriptive statistics table is
going to output into cell G2.
And before we press OK, I just want to
make sure that we check the summary
statistics box down here.
Otherwise, we're not going to get any
statistics actually returned to us in cell
G2.
So we want to make sure summary statistics
is checked and then we can press OK.
OK, let's move this chart over again to
the right hand side.
So you can see here what we've got is some
descriptive statistics data.
I'm going to go through what all of these
mean in a moment, but I just want to tidy
things up slightly first.
This cell down here, H17, that has a zero
in it is unnecessary.
So I'm just going to delete or clear the
contents of that cell by pressing delete
on the keyboard.
And we can rename this table to
descriptive statistics.
So I'm just selecting cell G2.
Currently, you can see in the formula bar
at the top that the name in that cell, the
text in that cell is column one.
And we can see that appearing here.
So I'm just going to write over that with
descriptive statistics.
Press enter.
And lastly, before I move on to explaining
what all these statistics are, we're just
going to tidy up some of the formatting of
these numbers.
So I'm going to select the values that we
have for the mean, standard error, median
mode, standard deviation, sample variance.
And I'm going to right click within that
selection and go to format cells and then
format them to percentages with two
decimal places and press OK.
In fact, what I might do is just seeing
that it may need some extra decimal places
there to see all the numbers.
So I'm going to go back into that right
click in that selection format cells
percentage.
We'll change this to three decimal places.
I'm going to do the same thing for range,
minimum and maximum.
They need to be percentages as well.
So we'll just make them percentages to
three decimal places.
So it's consistent.
And then our other numbers with decimal
places here.
So kurtosis, skewness and sum.
I'll just select those in turn and format
them as numbers to three decimal places
rather than all these additional decimal
places that we don't really need.
Okay, so we've got our summary statistics
calculated now and tidied up.
So we've reformatted them a little bit so
we can see the values more clearly.
And let me describe what some of these
statistics actually mean now.
And I'm going to start with what we call
the measures of centrality.
And all of these measures that I'm going
to talk about now basically try to
describe where the center of the data set
that we're looking at lies.
So basically the values are the mean, the
mode and the median.
The mean is what you guys will typically
know as the average.
It's the equally weighted average of all
the data points in the series.
The median is the middle number if you
were to order the data points from
smallest to largest.
And the mode is the most commonly
occurring value in the data series.
So as I said, all of these statistics are
calculated to give you an idea of where
the center of the data set lies.
We've then got some measures of dispersion
in our values for standard deviation and
variance here.
These values basically summarize the
dispersion of the data points around the
mean of the data set.
And in a normally distributed set of data,
such as data on human height or weight.
You typically expect to see around 68% of
the data lying within one standard
deviation from the mean.
And 95% of the data within two standard
deviations from the mean.
And 99% within three standard deviations.
And part of what we're going to do in the
subsequent analysis is compare how our
data set here compares with those values
that we'd expect to see in a normally
distributed data set.
Now, if at this stage you're not really
following what I mean about or what I mean
when I talk about normally distributed
data or you're unclear with any of the
descriptive statistics that I've been
talking about,
then you'll need to have a read through of
our introduction to statistics PDF in the
download section for this video.
And hopefully that gives you a better idea
of what I'm trying to say here.
Let's go on to some more values now.
We've got values for kurtosis and
skewness.
Effectively, these values tell us how
normally the data is distributed.
And Excel measures something called excess
kurtosis rather than kurtosis itself.
And if the value for excess kurtosis is
higher than zero, then we know that the
distribution of our dataset is peakier
around the mean and has fatter tails than
a normally distributed dataset.
Equally, if we look at our skewness value
and that's somewhere different to the
value of zero, then we know that it's not
normally distributed as well.
So a skewness value of over zero is a
positive skew.
And that means that a higher proportion of
the data lies in the positive tail than a
normal distribution would predict.
And if it's negative, then a higher
proportion of data lies in the negative
tail than a normal distribution would
predict.
And I'm going to refer back to these
statistics a little bit when we look at
the empirical distribution of our month on
month percentage change data series.
So those are the key statistics that you
need to pay attention to.
But there are some other useful ones here
as well to give you an idea about the sort
of range and depth of the data series.
The first we've got is the count down
here.
So that counts the number of data points
in the data series.
We've also got values for the minimum, the
maximum and the range.
Okay, they should be fairly self
explanatory.
The minimum is the lowest value in the
data series.
The maximum is the highest value.
And the range is the difference between
those two values.
Okay, so that's our descriptive statistics
done for the month on month percentage
change data for M2 money supply.
Let's have a look at the year on year
percentage change data now in column D.
We're going to go through the same process
in calculating our descriptive statistics
table for that data.
So I'm just going to go to data analysis
on the ribbon in the data tab and click on
that.
Choose descriptive statistics as our
analysis tool again and press okay.
We're going to change the input range this
time for the data that we're looking at
and want to calculate the summary
statistics for.
So the input range now is going to go from
cell D2 and I'm going to press control
shift down twice to get to the bottom of
this data set to D746.
I'm then going to change the output range.
It's not going to be G2 because we don't
want it to overwrite this data that we
have for our monthly or month on month
percentage change data.
I'm actually going to put it well out the
way into cell N2 over here.
And that's because we're going to have a
lot more analysis to do for our month on
month data in these columns over here.
And then we've already got the summary
statistics checkbox ticked.
So that's okay.
We can just press okay there and it's
going to put all of our descriptive
statistics for our year on year percentage
change data into cell N2.
To tidy this up, we just do the same as
what we've done previously.
I'm going to delete the zero at the bottom
of the table.
I'm going to change all the numbers that
we need to two percentages to three
decimal places in exactly the same way as
we did previously.
And also for our values that we're keeping
as decimals, but to less decimal places
than they already show.
Okay.
A couple of things to notice very quickly
about this data.
You can see that the measures for
centrality.
So I'm talking about the mean and the
median here really are considerably higher
for the year on year percentage change
data than for our month on month changes,
as is the dispersion of the data seen in
the range, the variance and the standard
deviation as well.
That all makes sense because we're
measuring percentage changes over a longer
period of time.
So we'd expect those changes to be larger
on aggregate.
What's also quite interesting is that on a
relative basis, the year on year data
looks to be closer to normally distributed
than the month on month data, which we can
see in lower values for ketosis and
skewness as well.
A couple of other things I quickly want to
point out here as well is that we've got
an error value for the mode.
That's basically because no value was
repeated more than once.
So there isn't a value for the most
commonly occurring number in this data set
for year on year change.
And also the count is lower.
Okay.
733 versus 744.
That's because we can't calculate year on
year percentage change for as many data
points as we can month on month percentage
change for obvious reasons.
So that's why there's a lower count there.
Now at this stage, I just want to point
out that for the rest of the video, I'm
just going to be going through the
analysis processes for our month on month
percentage change data for M2 money
supply.
Rather than a year on year percentage
change data.
And that is just because the year on year
analysis is going to be identical in
methodology.
And I'm going to include that in the
template file for you guys as well, which
you can download and I'll also show you
later in the video.
So basically the process for analyzing
both the year on year percentage change
data and month on month percentage change
data is exactly the same.
So I don't think it's worth going over it
twice because for one, it doesn't cover
any new material.
Secondly, it's going to take quite a lot
of extra time if we did.
And thirdly, you guys are going to have
access to all of that analysis anyway in
the template download.
So what we're going to do next is try to
build a better picture about how our month
on month data is distributed and answer
some questions such as, you know, what the
proportion is of data that lies within
certain ranges.
So for example, what proportion of month
on month percentage change data has a
value between 1% and minus 1%.
To do that, what I'm going to do is create
what's called a histogram table and chart.
That's going to look at the monthly rates
of change in M2 money supply.
And that'll help us understand what normal
and abnormal rates of change are given the
entire historical data set that we're
looking at.
Now to generate histogram data, we're
going to need to count the number of data
points that lie within certain ranges, as
I said.
And to do this, we're going to have to
create intervals to count the data points
in between.
So for example, for our monthly data, I'm
going to set intervals that start from
minus 0.8% and increase in increments of
0.15% all the way up to 1.9%.
Then we'll calculate the number of M2
month on month percentage change data
points that lie within or between each of
those intervals.
And that data can then be plotted in a
chart and also sort of counted in a table
and we can look at its empirical
distribution.
Now, if you guys are wondering how I came
up with those interval values that I just
mentioned before, it's basically just
because I've already looked at the
distribution.
So I know what's reasonable for this data
series.
If you guys are carrying out distribution
analysis for other sets of data
yourselves, then I suggest when you're
creating intervals, you take into
consideration the mean of the data set,
the standard deviation and the range of
the data, which is why we've gone over or
part of the reason why we've gone over
those descriptive statistics first.
And that should give you a good idea of
the intervals that you should set to make
sure that you visually can capture all of
the data properly.
Okay, so I'm going to start entering the
intervals that we want for this month on
month data now starting in cell C18.
So if you remember the first interval that
I said that we're going to use or the
lowest interval is going to be minus 0.8%.
Okay, that is as a decimal minus 0.008.
So I'm putting that in cell G18.
And then the next interval, if you
remember, I said we're going to increase
the intervals in increments of 0.15%.
So the next interval would be minus 0.0065
as a decimal.
And that's an increase of 0.15% as an
increment.
Now you remember before we've talked about
copying formulas down and across in Excel.
But what you can also do is copy down and
across patterns.
Okay, what I mean by patterns is we can
put in values like we've just done in here
in a couple of cells or in more than two
cells.
And you can then copy whatever pattern
Excel recognizes in those values down or
across.
So if I select those two cells and then
click and drag the little green box in the
bottom right of the selection downwards,
that's going to start copying down
whatever pattern Excel recognizes with
these two values.
And basically in this case, it's going to
recognize the pattern, which is a
difference between the two values.
So it's recognizing the incremental
increase of 0.15%.
So I can just drag that down until we get
to plus 1.9% or in decimal 0.019.
You can see that next to my cursor at the
moment, and that will be in cell B36.
So that's a really easy way to copy down
constant incremental changes in decimal
values.
Okay, so let's head that column with
intervals in cell G17.
And now what we can do is use Excel's data
analysis tool as we did before, but this
time to count the number of data points
that lie between all of these intervals
that we've just created.
So what I'm going to do is within the data
tab on the ribbon, go to data analysis
again.
This time I'm going to go to histogram and
press OK.
And our input range for the histogram is
going to be all our original data sets.
So our month on month percentage change
data set.
So I'm just going to select from cell C2,
control shift down to make sure I go to
the bottom of the data.
So C2 to C746 in the input range.
The output range I'm going to select by
clicking inside this box here, scroll back
to the top of the sheet.
The output range I'm going to make H17.
And we also need to remember to set our
bin range.
Now our bin range is basically our range
of intervals that we're going to use.
So if we select this bin range box here
and then inside that box, we basically
click and drag over the cell references
for our intervals.
So that would be G18 to G36.
We're then ready to go.
We can press OK.
And when you do that, you will see that
it's created a table with all of our bins,
which is our intervals.
OK, they're called bins because it's
almost like a bucket.
So ranges it's referring to.
These are our bin values.
They're the same as our intervals,
basically, because they create bins within
which data points for within.
OK, now the frequency is the number of
data points that fall within these bins
within these ranges defined by our
intervals.
Now I'm going to explain all this a bit
more in a moment.
But before we go on to that, let's just
quickly format these decimals for our
intervals and bins at two percentages to
two or three decimal places,
just because it's much easier to read them
as percentages than decimals when we're
dealing with values like this.
So I've selected all of the intervals and
bin values that we have here.
I'm going to right click within the
selection, go to format cells and then
just format them as percentages to three
decimal places.
OK, so that's just a little bit easier to
read there.
You can now see what I meant when I was
saying we're starting at minus 0.8%.
We're going up in intervals of 0.15% until
we get to a maximum of 1.9%.
OK, and all of those intervals then define
define these ranges.
So if we take a look at the frequency
column here, let's start at the top.
What this is basically telling us is that
there's no data points in our month on
month percentage change data set that have
a value of less than minus 0.8%.
If we follow on from that, we can also see
that there's no observations that lie
between 0.8% or minus 0.8% and minus
0.65%.
So continuing with that logic, you can see
the amount of data points that lie within
the ranges defined by the intervals.
So if we go on to the next one, there's
one data point that is in between the
value of minus 0.65% and minus 0.5% and so
on.
OK, and then roughly somewhere in the
middle of the data set, for example,
there's 146 data points that lie between
plus 0.4% and plus 0.55%.
So basically 146 times out of all of the
historical months that we have for our M2
money supply, the month on month
percentage change has been between 0.4%
and 0.55%.
OK, that's what that's saying.
At the beginning, the first range defined
by these intervals is less than the lowest
value that we see.
And the last range that we have down here,
so where there's nine data points, refers
to more than or greater than the highest
interval that we have set of 1.9%.
So you can see already here how this gives
us an idea of how month to month
percentage changes in M2 money supply are
distributed.
And there's lots of data points that we
can see around the mean and the median.
OK, around 0.55%, 0.7%, that sort of
range.
And much less in the extremes or the tails
of the distribution, i.e. down in the sort
of minus 0.5% range and also the kind of
plus 1.5% range and higher.
We can also see how that relates to our
descriptive statistics.
For example, we calculated a positive skew
before of 4.826.
And remember, I said that that skew, a
positive skew means that there's a higher
percentage of extreme moves on the
positive side than there are on the
negative side.
And we can see that in this data here.
It's skewed.
The extreme values are skewed in the
positive side as opposed to the negative
side.
OK, so before we go any further, I just
want to make these ranges a little
clearer.
So in the next column, column J, what I'm
going to do is write out these ranges in
text format so it's easier to understand
and make reference to.
And this is going to come in useful for
our chart later on as well.
So basically, instead of having to try and
interpret what the range is that these
various intervals refer to, we're going to
write it out in a very clear text format
instead in column J.
So in cell J 17, I'm going to title this
column with range.
And then in the cell below that J 18, I'm
going to start typing in the range that
this interval refers to.
And I'm going to write that in text
format.
And the way or one way we can write this
in text format in Excel is by using a
formula with quotation marks.
So I can put in, for example, equals,
that's how we start all of our formulas in
Excel, then open quotation marks and type
in less than minus 0.8% and close
quotation marks and press enter.
And you'll see that then that writes out
in text format, the range that obviously
refers to the adjacent interval or bin
value.
Okay.
So equally for the next one, what I can do
is type that in as well with an equation
and quotation marks.
But before I do that, let me show you what
would happen if you just tried to type
this in as numbers straight into the cell
without a formula and quotation marks in
this instance.
Okay.
So the range that this refers to is minus
0.8% to minus 0.65%.
Okay.
If I try and enter that in now in this
cell, Excel is going to confront me with
an error.
And the reason for that is it's confused
because basically we started off what
we've entered into the cell with a
mathematical operator.
So it thinks that it's going to be some
sort of calculation and it's not
necessarily text.
That wouldn't have actually been an issue
with the first one because we started off
with text.
So it formats the whole thing as text.
But with this one and the rest of the
ranges that we type out, this is a
problem.
That's why I'm saying a good way to get
around this is use an equal sign and put
everything in quotation marks.
That way Excel knows that we're trying to
write this out as text instead of using
numbers or calculations or anything like
that.
Okay.
So you guys get the idea.
I'm just going to go ahead now and write
out all of these ranges in that same
format so that we've got a good list of
text ranges.
That's really easy for us to refer to.
Okay.
So that's our text ranges done.
What I want to do next is draw your
attention back to our frequency column.
So column I, this data that we have here.
And I want to point out that whilst it's
interesting and useful to understand the
absolute number of observations in each
bin range,
it isn't actually as valuable as knowing
the percentage frequency of those
observations.
And what I mean by that is the number of
observations within each range as a
percentage of the total number of data
points in the series that we're looking
at.
The series in this case obviously being
the month on month percentage change of M2
money supply that we see in column C here.
So let's improve our understanding by
calculating these frequencies as
percentages now.
And I'm going to do that in column K and
start in cell K18 with a formula, which is
equals.
And I'm going to make a reference to I18
and then divide by a reference of H16.
Now, what this formula is doing is
basically taking the absolute count or
number of observations for our first bin
range.
So less than minus 0.8% and dividing that
by the total count of all the observations
we see in the data series.
Okay.
Now, obviously in this case, we're
dividing 0 by 744.
That's going to equate to a percentage of
0%.
But what we want to do is basically create
a formula that we can use when we copy
down to quickly calculate these
percentages for all of the bin ranges that
we have.
Now, you've seen already how we can drag
down formulas when we did when we
calculated percentage change values for
column C and D.
And the reason why we could drag those
formulas down is because we took advantage
of Excel's dynamic cell referencing.
Okay.
Or relative cell referencing, meaning the
formulas changed their referencing to
cells based on what formulas, what cells
the formulas were input to.
Okay.
Now, in this case, if we keep this total
formula as completely dynamic, then as we
copy this formula down, let me just go
ahead and do this now.
So I'm entering the formula into that
first cell there.
You can see we've got a value of zero,
which is what we'd expect.
As I copy these formulas down, you'll see
that these values don't make any sense.
The reason that they don't is, for
example, if we look at this second one
here that has a value error, it now
references the absolute frequency for our
second bin range, which is correct.
I 19, but it divides it by the value that
we see in H 17, which doesn't make any
sense.
That's the title of our bin column.
We want it to keep on referencing H 16, no
matter what cell we copy these formulas
down to.
So what we need to do is change our cell
reference for H 16 to a fixed cell
reference rather than a relative cell
reference.
Okay, so I'm going to delete the contents
of those cells that I've just copied down
there, go back into our top formula, I 18
divided by H 16.
And with the cursor next to our cell
reference for H 16, I'm going to press F4
on the keyboard and that's going to cycle
through different ways to fix that
reference.
And it uses dollar signs to indicate how
that cell reference is fixed.
Okay.
When we're looking at cell references in
Excel, you guys obviously know it
references the column followed by the row
number.
So column letter followed by row number.
Whatever you put a dollar sign before in a
cell reference fixes that column or row.
So if I have a dollar sign just before the
H, it will fix the column.
If I have a dollar sign before the H and
the 16, the column letter and the row
number, it will fix the entire reference,
both the column and the row.
And also obviously we can fix the
reference just the row as well.
So in this case, what I'm going to do is
cycle through these various fixed
reference options that we have until I get
a dollar sign before the H and before the
16, meaning that cell reference is
completely fixed or locked as we copy this
formula down or across.
Okay.
So I'm going to press enter now and then
copy this formula down.
And now we have all the correct formulas
that we need to calculate the percentage
of observations that we see within each
range that we're looking at.
And we can check that now just by
selecting, for example, this last cell
here and checking how the formula is
working.
We can still see that it's referencing the
correct value, the correct cell for the
absolute number of observations in the bin
range that we're looking at the associated
or adjacent bin range.
And we can see that it's dividing that
value still by our fixed reference for the
count in the entire data series.
So that's fine.
We know that's working.
Let's now select all of those cells and
format them by right clicking within that
selection formatting the cells as a
percentage to three decimal places.
And what we'll then see is very clearly
the percentage of observations that we
have that lie within each range that we've
created.
Now, another way of describing the
percentage frequency calculations that
we've just made is by referring to them as
probability values.
Since they do actually represent the
empirical probability of data points lying
within these various ranges that we've
created.
So what I'm going to do is head this
column that we've just created with the
word probability.
And what that basically allows us to say
is if we just pick out a value here, for
example, down here, if we're looking
within the range of 1.15%, 1.3%, remember
that is a reference to the range of M2
month on month money supply growth that we
would see.
We can say that there is a 2.15% chance or
probability that our M2 month on month
percentage growth will be between those
two values.
And you can obviously apply that logic to
any of the values that you see in this
probability column.
Now, remember, obviously, this is on an
empirical basis, meaning it's on the basis
of looking at the historical data that we
have.
But that is a reasonable way to assess
these values.
Okay, so we're almost finished with this
histogram table.
But there is one more column that I want
to calculate to give us even more of an
understanding about the distribution and
empirical probabilities of various values
in the data set.
And I'm going to head this next column
here, cu.probability.
And basically in this column, we're going
to calculate the cumulative probabilities
for this data set.
And what I mean by that is we're going to
calculate or add up sequentially all the
probability values that we see in column K
starting from the lowest range and then
ending with the highest range until we
basically account for 100% of the data.
So let me start putting in these formulas
now so you see what I mean.
So in cell L18 here, I'm just going to
make this cell equal to the value that we
see in K18.
Okay, our probability for the lowest range
less than minus 0.8%.
What I'm then going to do in the cell
below that in L19, I'm going to add the
cumulative probability that we have
calculated in the cell above L18.
So I'm going to add the probability to the
lowest range plus the probability of the
new range.
So minus 0.8% to minus 0.65% and the
probability for that range basically.
And then I'm going to copy that formula
down and you'll see that it then basically
adds in a cumulative fashion,
all of the probabilities assigned to the
various ranges that we've created until we
account for 100% of the data.
So why is this useful to us?
Basically, it gives us a really quick and
easy way to say that there's an X%
empirical probability that data is less
than a certain value.
So for example, we could say here that
there's a 7.392% chance that on any given
month, M2 growth will be less than 0.1%.
And equally, we can apply the same logic
in the inverse.
So for example, we could say that there's
roughly a 5% chance that M2 growth will be
greater than 1.15%.
Since we know that there's roughly a 95%
chance that it will be less than 1.15%.
Okay, so already at this stage, we're
starting to build a really good picture
about what we should expect from M2 growth
on a month on month basis.
And what might be considered normal and
what might be considered abnormal.
Okay, so that's our histogram table
completed.
What I want to show you now is how you can
visually assess this data in the form of a
histogram chart.
So to do that, I'm just going to select
down here cell G39.
Then I'm going to go to insert on the
ribbon and select a 2D column chart.
You'll see that then that presents me with
an empty chart area that I can move
around.
I'm going to move that down below our
histogram table and make it a little bit
bigger.
I'm then going to right click within the
chart area and go to select data so we can
add some data to this chart.
I'm then going to press the add series
button on the left hand side in this new
dialog box and give the series name or
reference the series name by selecting
cell K17.
Okay, which is just called probability and
the series values that we're going to
select are all the values from K18 to K37.
So all of our probability values for the
various ranges that we have.
So just make sure you overwrite whatever
was in here before, if anything, and just
click and drag to select all the
appropriate values.
So it should look something like this.
Okay, then we can press OK.
We've now got some data in the chart you
can see behind this dialog box.
And that is our probability series.
But we also want to make sure that we add
some axis labels.
And this is where the text ranges come in
handy that I created earlier.
So I'm going to click edit for this
horizontal axis label category.
We're then going to reference in this box
here all of our text ranges just by left
clicking and dragging over all of those
cells.
So that is J18 to J37.
I'll then press OK and press OK again.
We can take a look at our chart and we can
see now that we've got a decent looking
column chart showing the probability or
frequency percentage of data of
occurrences that land within these various
ranges.
Okay, for M2 growth.
Now I've already been through how you can
change the aesthetics of charts.
So I'm not going to make any big changes
here.
The only thing I want to do is make sure
we change the chart title and reduce its
size and also give this Y axis a title as
well.
So the chart title I'm just going to make
equal to M2 month on month percentage
month on month percentage histogram.
Okay, I'm just doing that by selecting the
title and then typing over it.
I'm then going to reduce the text size as
I showed earlier by selecting the chart
title.
I'll go to home on the ribbon and just
reduce the font size up here and then to
add a Y axis title.
What we can do is click on the chart, go
to design at the top on the ribbon, then
choose add chart element on the left hand
side.
Go to axis titles and choose a primary
vertical axis title.
You can see that adds an axis title on the
left there.
We can just select the text that's in that
box, delete it and then type over it with
something new.
So I'm just going to type over it with
probability.
Okay, because these values, this axis
represents the probability of these
various ranges occurring basically.
Okay, and actually I think we can, I'll
select that Y axis title, go to home again
and just make the font slightly bigger.
Okay, so at this stage we can now visually
assess the distribution of monthly M2
percentage growth.
And that just makes it easier to
understand really what all these numbers
are actually referring to.
So you can see that the curve of the data
that we have is roughly bell shaped, which
makes us think that the data is normally
distributed.
But as I've already hinted at with the
values of kurtosis and skew that we've
seen in our descriptive statistics, it's
actually quite different.
The data is peakier around the mean.
Okay, so around these values here and the
tails or extremes in the data are fatter
as well.
So basically the values that we see in
these extreme ranges in the low and the
high end have more occurrences than we'd
expect in a normal distribution.
Okay, what I'm going to do now is take
this a step further and show you how to
calculate the differences between this
distribution and a normal distribution by
doing some standard deviation analysis.
But before we go on to that, let's just
tidy up what we have already in terms of
our analysis tables that we've created and
add some definition to to these tables.
And what I mean by that basically is doing
some basic formatting changes in terms of
adding borders and maybe coloring some of
the cells as well.
Okay, now obviously this stage when you go
through this yourselves, you can kind of
change the aesthetics of the sheet however
you want a bit like I said with charts as
well.
So this is just to give you an idea of the
kind of steps that you can take to help
add some definition to the various aspects
that you have in your spreadsheet.
So what I'm going to start by doing is
selecting all of the analysis that we've
done up in this section here, all the
cells and basically removing the borders
that are already there because you can see
some lines, some borders that have
basically been pulled through when we've
done our data analysis.
So I'm going to basically select all of
those cells, go to home on the ribbon and
then look at the border menu on the left
hand side and just make sure that I choose
no border within that border dropdown.
And you'll see when I do that, it gets rid
of all those borders that we had
previously.
Now we're going to add back some borders,
but in a more structured way.
So I'm going to select just the histogram
table here and with that selected, I'm
going to go back to our border menu and
add all borders.
Okay, so that adds all borders basically
to every cell that I just selected.
And with that selection still in place,
I'm then going to add some thick outside
borders.
Okay, so I'm going to the same place in
the dropdown border menu, this time
choosing thick outside borders instead of
all borders.
And you'll see what that does.
Basically, it just adds some definition to
that entire table so we can sort of see
things a little bit more clearly there.
Next, what I'm going to do is add a thick
outside border to our descriptive
statistics as well to kind of define that
section from the histogram table.
So I've just selected the descriptive
statistics cells and then clicked on thick
outside border there.
And you can see we've got the same thing
occurring.
You'll notice that by default in Excel,
grid lines are basically shown to define
all the different cells.
So those are those faint sort of gray
lines you see running across rows and
column intersections.
And we can obviously see those in our
descriptive statistics as well.
Now, instead of adding some inside borders
or all borders, as I did with these cells
in the histogram table, I'm not going to
I'm basically going to get rid of inside
borders here and just leave this thick
outside border.
But I don't want these grid lines to show
up either.
So I'm selecting all the cells in the
descriptive statistics table.
And what I'm going to do to get rid of
those is just color the cells or fill the
color of the cells with white.
Okay, so I'm choosing white from the fill
color drop down menu up here in the home
tab.
And you'll see when I do that, it just
colors all the cells white.
And so it gets rid of those faint grid
lines that we saw there.
Okay, we're almost done, I think, in
tidying this up, but it probably makes
sense to make our titles bold.
So let's go back to the histogram table
now.
I'll select all the titles that we have in
that table and just press control B on the
keyboard to make them bold.
Remember, you can also do that by going to
the bold button up here in the home tab on
the ribbon.
I'm going to do the same with our
descriptive statistics title in cell G2.
And I'll do the same again for all of the
titles that we have for our individual
descriptive statistics.
Okay, so all of these cells here, I'm just
going to select them and make them bold as
well.
Okay, so it's looking looking pretty good
now.
There's just one more thing I think that
I'll do before I go on to creating this
standard deviation table or analysis that
I was talking about.
And that is selecting cell G1 to L1 up
here.
And what I'm going to do is create a title
for this whole analysis section that we're
creating.
Okay, to do that, selecting these cells,
I'm going to merge them.
So in the home tab on the ribbon, I'm
going to click merge in center.
That's going to merge all of those cells
into one.
Then I'm going to type in a title for this
entire analysis section, which is just
going to be M2 money supply month on month
percentage change.
Okay, and I'll make that bold as well.
And we can give this a thick outside
border.
Okay, so that title is basically applying
to all of the analysis that we're doing
below in this section here.
And we've got a little bit of space here.
That's deliberate because we're going to
move on to a couple more smaller analysis
tables.
The first of which I mentioned just
previously is going to be looking at these
standard deviation bounds.
So more specifically, what we're going to
do is create a table that identifies the
upper and lower bounds for one, two and
three standard deviations from the mean.
And remember, if you're unsure about what
a standard deviation is at this stage, you
can refer back to the intro to statistics
PDF that I mentioned earlier.
Once we have those bounds, we can then
count the number of observations that lie
within those bounds and compare them to
what a normal distribution would predict.
So what I'm going to do is basically
create the row and column headings first
for this analysis table, and then we'll
fill in the calculations afterwards.
So in cell I2 here, I'm just going to
title this new analysis table and the
title I'm going to put in is STD space DEV
space bounds.
Okay, standard deviation bounds.
To the right of that in cell J2 to cell
L2, I'm going to put in one, two and three
standing for one, two and three standard
deviations.
And then in the cell below I2, so I3 and
down from that, I'm going to type upper
bound, lower bound, actual count.
So don't worry too much about what these
mean just now, actual percentage count and
normal percentage count.
So the first thing I'm going to do here is
basically create our bound values for one
standard deviation from the mean.
I'm going to start with the upper bound
first.
So in cell J3, we're going to enter a
formula to calculate this upper bound.
I'm going to put in equals, then make a
reference to our mean in our descriptive
statistics, that's cell H4.
I'm going to add to that in brackets one
times the standard deviation value that we
have in our descriptive statistics.
Now we can just type one asterix and then
make a reference to our standard deviation
cell.
Or what we could do is instead of putting
one, we could just make a reference to our
standard deviation bound cell up here.
So cell J2, which is obviously equal to
one.
Okay, so you can see from this formula
basically we're creating an upper bound
for one standard deviation from the mean.
Because we're taking the mean, we're
adding one times the standard deviation
that we have for our data.
Now I could just enter that formula there.
But what I want to do is make this a
little bit more robust by making sure we
can copy this across and down.
So I'm going to fix the cell references
for the mean and standard deviation.
So that's H4 and H8.
To do that, I'm just clicking inside those
cell references within the formula and
pressing F4 on the keyboard.
And that's adding those dollar signs
before the column letter and row numbers
for each of those references.
And also we want to fix the row, but not
the column for the reference to one, two
and three standard deviation bounds.
Okay, so the J2 reference here.
So I'm going to press F4 when my cursor is
within that J2 reference.
That's going to fix the whole thing.
We don't want that.
So I'm going to press it again.
And then you'll see that it's just got the
dollar sign before the row number and not
the column letter.
So it's just fixing the row, not the
column.
That's what we want.
After that, I'm just going to press enter
and you'll see there that I've got an
upper bound value for one standard
deviation from the mean.
I'm going to copy this formula down to the
lower bound row.
And you'll see that actually at this
stage, we've just got exactly the same
value.
That's incorrect at the moment because we
need to make a minor adjustment to our
formula for the lower bound calculations.
So I'm going to double click inside the
lower bound calculation here.
And instead of it being an addition sign,
I'm going to change that to a subtraction
sign in the formula.
So basically we're taking the mean and
we're minusing one times the standard
deviation to create a lower bound for one
standard deviation from the mean.
And you can see now we've got an upper
bound of about 1%, a lower bound for about
0.1% in terms of one standard deviation
from the mean.
Once we've got those formulas done, we can
just select those two cells and copy these
formulas across to 2 and 3 standard
deviations from the mean by left clicking
and dragging on the little green box at
the bottom right of the selection across
to column L.
And you'll see now that we've got values
for the upper and lower bounds for two and
three standard deviations from the mean as
well as one standard deviation from the
mean.
And you can go in and check that these
formulas are working correctly.
For example, we can see here in the upper
bound for two standard deviations from the
mean, it's still referencing our fixed
reference for the mean and standard
deviation.
But it's moved our reference for the
number of standard deviations from the
mean from cell J2 to K2 and that's
correct.
The same logic would apply for the rest of
these cells as well.
So now we know our upper and lower bounds
for one, two and three standard deviations
from the mean.
Let's count the number of observations
that we see in our M2 month on month data
that have values between these upper and
lower bounds that we've created.
So I'm going to start in cell J5 here and
type in a new formula.
So I'm going to put equals and it's going
to start off with a function.
The function is going to be count ifs.
So I'm typing in count ifs here, then open
brackets.
And I'm just going to go ahead and
basically write this whole formula out and
then come back and explain it afterwards.
Okay, so I've written in count ifs, open
brackets.
I'm then going to make a reference to
column C, which is our month on month M2
data.
I'm going to fix that reference, put in a
comma to move on to the next parameter of
this function.
I'm then going to put in our first
criteria, which is it's going to be
greater than or equal to our lower bound
for one standard deviation from the mean.
So in quotation marks, I'm going to put
greater than or equal to operators, close
the quotation marks and link that with an
ampersand to a cell reference, which is
going to be J4 representing our lower
bound.
Then I'm going to put in another comma,
choose column C again and fix that
reference, then another comma and choose
another criteria.
This time it's going to be in quotation
marks less than and join that with an
ampersand to another cell reference, cell
J3 and close brackets.
Whenever you have a function in Excel,
it's always going to have a bunch of
parameters that you need to fill in within
brackets after you write in the function.
Okay, now this function is called count
ifs.
It counts the number of data points in an
array that you select.
So the array in this example is column C.
Okay.
Our M2 month on month percentage change
data and it counts the number of data
points in there subject to certain
criteria that you define.
Okay.
And how it works is in the first section,
you basically reference the array that you
want to count.
So column C in this case, after the comma,
you then define the first criteria that
you want to count.
Column C subject to.
And this is just an Excel quirk, really a
way of writing greater than or equal to
whatever is in cell J4.
Okay.
Don't worry too much that you have to put
greater than or equal to operators within
quotation marks and then link that with an
ampersand to J4.
It's just a quirk of Excel and you guys
will get used to it when you use functions
like this.
Then we move on to a second criteria
because again, remember, we don't want to
count all the data in column C that
fulfills just higher than the lower bound.
We need it to be higher than the lower
bound, but lower than the upper bound.
Okay.
So we've then got to define the criteria
range that we're looking at again.
So that's column C and then the criteria,
a second criteria that we're going to use,
which is less than cell J3.
So the upper bound.
So that's how that works.
Don't worry too much if that seems overly
complex at the moment.
I think once you guys start using formulas
and functions like this, you're going to
get really used to it and just understand
the little quirks of Excel and the kind of
logic that it uses.
Okay.
So I'm just going to enter that in now and
you'll see what happens.
Okay.
So we have a count of 620.
That means we have 620 data points, month
on month percentage change data points for
our M2 money supply out of 744 that fall
between these bounds.
So one standard deviation from the mean,
let's copy this formula across to two and
three standard deviations from the mean
and see what happens.
Okay.
So we've now got some values, some actual
counts for the number of data points that
lie between the upper and lower bound for
two standard deviations from the mean and
three standard deviations from the mean.
I'm just going to double click in these
formulas to check that they're working.
Okay.
So our column reference, they've stayed
fixed.
That's great.
And our reference to the criteria have
moved because we didn't fix those
references.
So that's great as well.
They're still referring or they're
referring to the appropriate upper and
lower bounds that we want.
Okay.
So that all looks good.
We can say that there's 729 data points
that lie within two standard deviations
from the mean and 736 data points that lie
within three standard deviations from the
mean.
Now, as I kind of covered before, when
you're doing analysis like this, it's
useful to see how much of the total data
these observations, these counts actually
represent, you know, as a percentage of
the total count.
So that's what we're going to do in this
next row here, actual percentage count.
And in cell J6, I'm going to type in a
formula to calculate this.
So equals the actual count reference.
So J5, the cell above it, divided by the
total count, which is cell H16.
Now, when we copy this formula across,
obviously we want the total count
reference to stay fixed.
This other one can move as we copy it
across.
So I'm just going to make sure that the
reference to H16 is fixed and I can press
enter and copy these values across.
And because these are percentages, we
should format them to display themselves
as a percentage.
So with all of these cells selected, I'm
going to right click within the selection,
go to format cells and format them as
percentages to three decimal places.
Okay.
And we can see that, you know, for
example, the 83% of the data in column C
lies between our upper and lower bound for
one standard deviation from the mean and
so on.
Okay.
Now, remember the point of this table was
to observe how these percentages may
differ from what a normal distribution
would predict in terms of the percentage
count
that a normal distribution has for one,
two and three standard deviations from the
mean.
Now, you guys will know from the intro to
statistics PDF that I've mentioned a
number of times that for one standard
deviation from the mean, a normal
distribution accounts for 68.2% of all the
observations.
For two standard deviations from the mean,
it's 95.4% of all observations.
And for three standard deviations from the
mean, it accounts for 99.7% of all
observations.
So what does this tell us?
Well, if we look at one standard deviation
from the mean, we can see that our data is
peakier.
Okay.
Around the mean within one standard
deviation because our data actually
accounts for 83% within one standard
deviation from the mean rather than what a
normal distribution would predict, which
is 68% of the data.
So that tells us it's peakier around the
mean than a normal distribution.
And that is backed up by our positive
kurtosis value that we saw earlier as
well.
However, as we go out to two and three
standard deviations from the mean, what
you'll see, or three standard deviations
particularly, what you'll see is that
actually our empirical data, our data that
we're looking at doesn't account for as
much of the distribution as a normal
distribution would predict.
Okay.
So our data within three standard
deviations from the mean accounts for
98.9% of the data.
Whereas in a normal distribution, three
standard deviations from the mean accounts
for 99.7% of the data.
That basically means that there's more
data lying outside this three standard
deviation bound on both the lower and the
upper side than a normal distribution
would predict.
Okay.
And that's what we said about fatter
tails.
Okay.
These tails of the distribution are larger
than what we would observe in a normal
distribution.
And again, that is backed up by one of the
first calculations that we did in our
descriptive statistics, which is the
kurtosis value that is greater than zero
or excess kurtosis value that's greater
than zero.
Okay.
To finish this off this table, let's just
format it and make it look a bit nicer.
I'm going to color all of these cells as
white, fill the color and then add a thick
outside border.
So I'm selecting all of those cells.
I'm going to add a thick outside border
there and just make all of our row and
column titles bold in this instance.
And I think I'll underline as well our
standard deviation bound cell here.
So the title for the entire table, cell
I2, by selecting that cell and pressing
Ctrl U and that underlines the text in
that cell.
You can also click on the underline button
up here in the home tab if you wish.
Okay.
So we've got space here now for our final
analysis table in this sheet.
And what we're going to do here is group
all of the M2 monthly percentage growth
numbers into positive numbers, negative
numbers and zero values.
And as before, what I'm going to do when
going through this analysis section is
start off by creating all of the column
and row titles.
And then we're going to start filling in
the calculations themselves.
So I'm going to start in cell J8 here with
column titles.
And I'm just going to put in positive data
as a title in that column and negative
data in K8 and zero in L8.
Then I'm going to enter row titles
starting in cell I9.
I'm just going to put in mean count
frequency percentage and then frequency
adjusted mean.
Okay.
So what I'm going to do now is calculate
the average of all the positive data
points in our month on month data set.
So that's column C.
And to do this, we're going to use a
function called average if which operates
in a very similar way actually to the
count ifs function that we used earlier.
So in cell J9, I'm going to type equals
average if then open brackets and we can
see the parameters that we need to fill in
here.
So we've got a range to define and some
criteria to define as well.
Let's start with the range.
That's just going to be column C, all of
our M2 month on month percentage change
data.
I'm going to fix that reference, put in a
comma in the function and move on to the
next parameter, which is our criteria.
And I'm just going to put in quotation
marks here greater than zero and close
brackets.
So that basically is just going to average
all of the data points in column C that
fulfill this criteria of being greater
than zero.
So basically all the positive data points.
Okay.
I can press enter there and we've got a
value.
I'm going to come back to formatting that
cell in a moment, but let's calculate this
for negative data as well.
So our average for our negative data
points, I'm going to drag the formula
across, step into the formula.
We can see that the range is still the
same column C. That's great.
But obviously the criteria we no longer
want to be greater than zero.
We want it to be less than zero.
So just by changing the mathematical
operator sign there, we can calculate the
average of all of our negative data points
in column C.
And then obviously the mean for all of our
zero data points is just going to be zero.
So I can just write in zero in that cell
there.
Let's format all of these as percentages.
So I'm selecting those cells, right
clicking in the selection, going to format
cells, choosing the percentage category.
And I'm going to put these rounding to
three decimal places.
Okay.
So we have our average for our positive
and negative data points.
Let's see how many of the data points in
column C, our month-on-month percentage
change data, are actually positive and how
many are negative.
Okay.
So to do that, we're going to use pretty
much identical formula as we did before.
This time for count.
So count if, not count ifs, because we're
only going to use one criteria this time.
So equals count if, open brackets, select
our range, which is column C, fix that
reference, move on to the criteria
parameter in the function.
And this time the criteria is just going
to be in quotation marks greater than zero
as it was with the average function that
we just put in.
And then going to copy that across.
And again, step into this formula that
we've got for our negative data and change
the mathematical operator from a greater
than sign to a less than sign.
So we just count the data points that are
less than zero.
And then finally, I'm going to copy this
formula across again for our zero values.
And instead of putting anything in
quotation marks or using operators, the
criteria that we want to just set is zero
or equal to zero.
So we can just put a zero in the criteria
parameter for that function.
And you'll see then that we've got zero
data points that fulfill that criteria.
Now, as always, it's useful to calculate
these counts as a percentage of the total
number of data points.
So in this frequency percentage row, I'm
just going to start in cell J11.
Type in the formula equals the count that
we see for positive data points.
Cell J10 divided by the total count that
we have in our descriptive statistics,
H16.
I'm going to fix the reference to that
total count and then enter that formula in
and copy that across.
To our other columns for our frequency
percentage count.
Okay.
And then with those cells selected, I'll
format them as percentages to three
decimal places.
And we can then see that how many sort of
data points we have that are positive,
negative or zero in our total data set.
So the vast majority, obviously positive
95% plus negative the rest.
And there's no data points that have a
value of zero.
Now we can calculate the probability or
frequency adjusted mean.
And this is basically just the weighted
mean for the positive, negative and zero
data groups.
And the means are weighted by the
probability of occurrence of each group.
And the sum of all of these frequency
adjusted means will equate to one.
So in this cell, J12, I'm just going to
type equals the mean for the positive data
set.
J9 times by the probability of occurrence
for positive data points, which is J11.
And that will give me the frequency
adjusted mean.
Now at the moment, you can see that it's
just returned a load of hashtags.
That's just because it's trying to write a
value to a lot more decimal places than
will fit in the cell.
So if you just right click on the cell
format that cell and limit the decimal
places to three, then we'll see what value
it is.
Okay.
And we can copy that formula across now to
our negative data points and our zero data
points.
And you'll see that we have a positive
data frequency adjusted mean of 0.57%, a
negative one of minus 0.005%.
And obviously our zero grouping returns a
0% frequency adjusted mean.
Now, if you add all of those up, so if I
select all of those cells and look at the
bottom of the Excel sheet down here,
you'll see the sum is 0.567%, which is
actually exactly the same as the mean for
the entire data set.
Okay.
So this is in short, just the probability
weighted mean for each data grouping.
Okay.
So this table basically just gives us an
idea of, you know, how often we can expect
positive or negative data points for M2
monthly percentage growth.
And it also gives us an idea of the
average value we might expect for both
positive or negative data points.
So let's finish this table off now by
tidying it up.
I'm going to select all the cells from I8
to L16 here.
And I'm going to color all of them as
white.
Then I'm going to just add a thick outside
border here and just make sure all of our
column titles and row titles are bold.
Okay.
So that's that analysis table done.
There's one more chart we should probably
plot.
And that is the monthly moves in M2 money
supply itself.
So to do this, let's insert a new chart at
the bottom of all of our analysis here.
So I'm going to scroll down the sheet a
little bit and just go to insert on the
ribbon and insert a 2D column chart and
reposition this chart area.
Make it a little bit bigger like our other
chart.
And then within this area, I'm going to
right click and go to select data so we
can add a data series to this chart.
And I'm going to click this add button on
the left hand side to add a series.
The series that we're going to add, as I
just said, is the M2 month on month
percentage change series.
So column C basically.
So the name that we're going to apply to
this series is just the title that we see
in cell C1.
So I'm just going to make a reference to
cell C1 in that box.
And series values that we have are just
going to go down from C2 to the end of the
data set.
So I'm just pressing control shift and
down twice on the keyboard there to
quickly select all of our month on month
data.
So that's C2 to C746, press OK, and then
we need to add our horizontal axis labels.
So I'm going to click edit here and make
sure we choose all the appropriate dates
for our month on month data.
So I'm going to choose from cell A2 down
to the end of the data set.
So A2 to A746, that's all the dates that
we need and press OK again.
Scroll back to the top of the sheet and we
can see that we've now got our M2 month on
month percentage change data in a column
chart format.
Now this looks OK as is, but there's a few
things that we can do to make the chart a
lot clearer to read.
So let's start by moving these dates from
the zero value of the Y axis to the bottom
of the chart.
And you'll see what I mean in a moment.
So if I double click the dates here, you
will see a format axis panel appear on the
right hand side.
And you just need to go down to the labels
tab and then select the label position as
low rather than next to axis.
And you'll see then the dates instead of
appearing next to that zero axis now
appear at the bottom of the chart.
And that just makes things a little bit
easier to read.
Now what we're going to do is reduce the
gaps between all of these columns and
color them in a different color.
So I'm going to double click the columns
themselves.
So the data itself in this chart.
And again, you'll see this format data
series panel appear on the right hand
side.
I'm going to make the gap width of these
columns zero.
So it will bunch all the columns together.
There won't be any gaps between them.
You might not see how that's changed just
yet, but it has actually removed gaps
between columns.
And then what we're going to do is go to
the fill and line options in this format
data series panel and go to the fill tab
and choose a solid fill.
And we're also going to tick the checkbox
that says invert if negative.
And what that's going to do is basically
cover color.
Sorry, the negative data points in a
different color.
And we can change these colors to whatever
we want.
You can see at the moment it looks like
we've got blue and black.
In actual fact, it's blue and white, but I
think it's got some borders there.
So anyway, let's just change the colors to
green for our positive values and red for
our negative values there.
So that's pretty much it in terms of what
you guys need to know in order to build
out this analysis yourselves.
As I touched on at the beginning, the
point of all of this really is to be able
to identify abnormal prints in M2 money
supply growth,
particularly on the upside.
So we can identify when the Fed is
stepping in to provide liquidity to
support the economy in terms of growth and
inflation and also, of course, markets.
By knowing what the distribution of M2
growth data looks like, as we've been
through here,
you should now have a good idea of what
values are typical and what values are
abnormal whenever new data comes out.
So for example, if a new monthly figure
came out that represents a 1.9% increase
in monthly M2 money supply, then you know
that this only really happens around 1% of
the time.
And so that would be abnormal, certainly
on a historical basis.
And so that would need to prompt those
questions that I posed at the beginning of
the video.
So things like, you know, asking
yourselves, does this line up with what
I'm seeing from money markets and other
leading indicators?
If not, what does the Fed know that I
don't know?
And maybe you need to do some more work to
understand what's going on in markets in
the wider economy if you don't know or
don't understand why these prints might be
occurring.
All else being equal, we should expect
significantly positive prints to improve
economic and market conditions going
forward because the Fed is providing
liquidity there.
But that being said, you know, the phrase
all else being equal, that never actually
realistically applies in a practical
sense.
So you always need to keep your eyes open
to other factors that we cover in the rest
of the video series as well, of course.
There is one more bit of Excel analysis
that I want to go through with you guys,
which might help you identify these
irregular prints.
And it's also going to give us a chance to
look back historically at what was
happening in markets when there have been
these big M2 prints over the previous
years.
So what we're going to do is basically
match up these M2 numbers or M2 growth
numbers with S&P 500 prices.
And we're going to calculate some
percentiles and then filter the data to
show us when these big percentage moves
happened in the past and briefly go
through what might have been causing them
in markets at those times,
or at least what was happening in markets
and the economy at those times.
So to carry out this next bit of analysis,
we're going to create a new sheet in this
spreadsheet file.
And we can do that easily by clicking on
the plus sign in the bottom left of the
spreadsheet window.
So that creates a new sheet.
And when you click on that, you'll see a
new sheets created and you can very easily
rename that sheet just by right clicking
on the current sheet name and going to
rename.
So I'm just going to name this sheet
historical analysis month on month or MOM.
So to start with in this sheet, what we
want to do is just copy in our monthly M2
data that we had in the previous sheet
into this one, except we're going to enter
it into row 24 and down.
And that'll become clearer as we go
through this analysis.
But basically I want to leave some space
at the top of the sheet for a chart and
some percentile analysis, which you'll see
later.
So if we go back to the M2 distribution
sheet, all I'm going to do is copy
basically all of the dates and the
observations that we see for M2 money
stock.
So columns A and B starting from the
title.
So cell A1 and B1 control shift and down
to select all of the data in those two
columns.
Press control C on the keyboard to copy
that data.
And then I'm going to paste it, as I said,
into row 24.
So cell A24 just here.
Now this data at the moment is all
squeezed up into fairly narrow columns.
So it's probably best that we increase the
width of these columns.
And as I said earlier, all you need to do
to do that is just basically click and
drag the intersections of these columns to
increase the width.
Okay, so I'm just going to do that.
So it tidies up the columns and what we're
looking at a little bit.
And you can also do the same thing for
rows.
So I'm just going to reduce this row
height a little bit.
So row 24.
Next, what we need to do is gather some
S&P 500 price data so that we can have a
look at what happened to equities in the
past and compare it with fluctuations that
we see in M2.
And typically we can get hold of S&P 500
data fairly easily from multiple different
sources.
Yahoo Finance is a prime example of being
able to get price data for various
different assets.
And typically that would be my go to
source for free price data.
But in this video, I'm going to use
investing.com.
And there's a good reason for that.
And I want to highlight this now at the
reason being basically that Yahoo Finance
data for the S&P 500 index is being a
little bit temperamental at the moment.
And the reason why I want to highlight
that is just because it shows that you
need to be flexible in the sources that
you gather data from.
So you're going to have to use a bit of
intuition sometimes and just be flexible
in how you gather data from multiple
different sources if you need to.
So I'm going to go onto my web browser now
and navigate to investing.com.
And when you do that, the page should look
something like this in order to find S&P
500 data.
You can just type in the search bar at the
top S&P 500 and then choose the S&P 500
index from the dropdown menu that you see
in front of you.
When you do that, you get taken to the S&P
500 index page and you can find a tab for
historical data down here.
And you just need to select that and then
it presents us with the historical data
page for the S&P 500 index.
Now we've got monthly data for our M2
money supply, so we want monthly data for
the S&P 500 as well.
So I'm going to change the timeframe on
the left hand side here from daily to
monthly.
And then I'm going to click into this
calendar box on the right hand side here
to select the time period for which we
want to gather prices for.
So you'll see when I do that, we can enter
some custom dates on the left hand side,
the start date and the end date.
Unfortunately, unlike Yahoo Finance, this
doesn't have a quick option just to choose
all data available and we actually have to
put in manual dates.
So what I'm going to do is just put in
January 1st 1950.
And when I do that, when I enter that into
the start date, you'll see that the
calendar flicks back as far as as far as
possible, which in this case is just to
the 1st of January 1970.
So that tells us that this data is only
going to go back to that period.
That's fine.
We don't actually need to change this for
now.
We can just leave it as 1950 and it will
go back as far as possible.
And then in the end date, we can choose
whatever we want.
So a recent day.
So I'm filming this in March.
I'll choose the 15th of March 2021.
And then we can just click apply and
download the data.
Now, as I said before, when we gathered
money supply data, for me, when I download
files, I get an option to open it, a
shortcut option at the bottom left of my
browser.
For you guys, that might be different
depending on the platform you're using and
the web browser you're using.
You just need to make sure you navigate to
that download and open the file.
And by default, this CSV file should open
in Excel.
So I've just clicked on that now to open
it.
And you can see here now we've got a file
with all of the S&P 500 prices going back
historically on a monthly basis, back as
far as the data set goes on investing.com,
which is to 1970.
We've got our prices in column B and we've
got our monthly dates in column A.
Now, basically what we want to do here is
copy across our S&P 500 prices from this
sheet into our historical analysis M2
month on month sheet here in this file
that we were just looking at.
And we want to make sure that when we copy
the S&P 500 prices across, they basically
line up with the correct dates.
So we're going to put them into the
correct rows.
And there's a few things to consider here
when we're doing this.
The first is that we've got a much longer
data set for M2 than we do for S&P 500
prices.
The M2 data set goes back to 1959, whereas
the S&P 500 data that we have goes back to
1970.
So we'll probably end up deleting all of
the data for M2 before 1970 so that we've
just got two columns that match.
The other thing to consider is if you look
at this M2 data, all the observation dates
are in an ascending order.
What that means is the top row in the data
set is the earliest date.
Okay.
And the bottom row in the data set is the
latest date.
And if we look at S&P 500 data, it's the
opposite way around.
The top row in the data set is the latest
date.
The bottom row is the earliest date.
And that means the order of dates is
descending.
So one way to fix that very quickly in
this S&P 500 data is select any one of the
title cells in the top row of the sheet
and then go to data on the ribbon and
click filter.
And then from there, we click inside the
date filter option here, this dropdown
arrow, and we can just sort by oldest to
newest rather than newest to oldest.
Okay, so I'm just going to click sort
oldest to newest, and you'll see that it
shuffles all of the data.
So it's now in an ascending order, not a
descending order.
The other thing that I want to make a note
of here in regards to dates and lining
this data up is if we go back to our M2
data, what you'll see is all the
observation dates on a monthly basis fall
on the first of each month.
Now, in actual fact, when you look at the
details of the M2 data from the Federal
Reserve Economic Database website, you'll
see that these M2 money stock values are
actually average values over the entire
month.
So they're not the M2 money stock values
on the first of every month.
They're actually the average for the
entire month.
So if we take this observation as an
example on the first of January, 1959,
this actually applies to the average value
for the whole of January, 1959.
Now for this analysis, this isn't really
going to affect things too much.
And we're not too worried about it taking
an average, but I just wanted to point
that out because it's just something that
you need to consider when you download
data in general.
Basically digging deeper and finding out,
you know, exactly how the data is
structured, because it might matter for a
different analysis that you're doing that
the exact dates don't line up.
Now, if we go back to our S&P 500 data
here, if you were to download this data
from Yahoo Finance, you would get the
prices at the end of the month.
And in the date column, it would show that
the the monthly dates are basically the
end of every month.
OK, so the last day, the closing values
for the last day of each month.
Now, when you download data from
investing.com, you get the first day of
every month.
But counterintuitively, really, and this
is again something to watch out for the
price data that you get for that month,
despite it saying it's from the first day
of each month is actually for the last day
of each month.
So it's still closing prices for the end
of the month, even though when you
actually select these date values in
column A, you can see it's always from the
first day of each month.
OK, so just something to bear in mind.
Like I said, for this for this analysis,
it doesn't really matter too much.
OK, we're going to be lining up end of
month prices with average money stock over
those months.
OK, so that that's not really an issue.
So to copy this data into our other
spreadsheet, I'm going to select from our
first date and first price that we have in
this S&P 500 data.
So February 1970, a price of 89.5.
I'm going to press Ctrl Shift and down to
select all of the data down to the bottom
of this sheet or down to the bottom of the
data set anyway.
Once that's selected, I'm going to copy it
by pressing Ctrl C and then I'm going to
go over to our M2 historical analysis
sheet.
And I'm going to make sure that I go down
to the February 1970 row.
OK, so down to here, row 158 and copy that
into this sheet.
Now, the reason why I've taken the dates
from the previous sheet from the S&P 500
data is just to make sure that when you do
copy it in, you can see that the date
columns match up.
But actually, we no longer need this date
column that we've just copied in once we
know that that's true.
OK, so what you can do is just left click
column C at the top here, right click
within that selection and go to delete.
And that will delete the date column
there.
Now, remember what I said we're going to
do with our data that's prior to February
1970.
So all of the data that we don't have or
all of the dates, sorry, that we don't
have S&P 500 data for.
We're basically just going to just delete
it, get rid of it.
So what I'm going to do is left click and
drag on these row numbers from row 157 all
the way to the first observation date that
we have.
That's going to select all of those rows
in their entirety.
I'm going to right click in that selection
and delete all of those as well.
And then what you can see is we've just
got a nice clean data set with our
observation dates, our M2 money stock
average values over those months.
And this will be S&P 500 prices.
So I'll title that column appropriately as
well and put that title in bold in cell
C24.
Okay, so remember what we're trying to do
here is a historical assessment comparing
abnormal M2 growth values on a monthly
basis to market events which will show up
in S&P 500 prices.
So we still need to calculate our M2 month
on month percentage change again.
So in this column column D in cell D24,
I'm just going to title this column M2
month on month percentage growth.
Okay.
And I'll make that column title bold.
We can also wrap the text of this column
title within the home tab on the ribbon
just to make sure the title fits in the
cell.
And then we're going to run our
calculations just as we did previously.
So basically all we need to do is in the
second cell down, I'm going to type in
that cell D26 equals the money stock that
we see for March 1970.
Okay.
Our second observation divided by our
first observation, the February 1970
observation.
Okay.
And that's going to calculate our growth
once we minus one from that equation as
well.
So when I press enter there, you'll see
that that returns to us a month on month
percentage growth value for M2 for that
month.
And I'm just going to copy that formula
down to the bottom of the sheet very
quickly by double clicking the little
green box in the bottom right of that
selection.
And then as we've done before, we're going
to format all of those cells as
percentages.
And I'm just going to basically right
click within that selection that I've just
copied down, go to format cells, choose
the category as a percentage, and then
choose three decimal places.
And that's it.
We've got our M2 month on month percentage
growth in percentage format.
And we can now look at those values and
see how they compare to S and P 500
prices.
So before we go on to some analysis and
drawing some comparisons between our M2
data and the S and P 500 prices, let's
just double check all of the data that we
have in this table.
So far, what I'm going to do is basically
scroll to the bottom of the data set with
control and down on the keyboard.
And we just want to check that all of our
M2 data lines up with S and P 500 data for
all of our observation dates.
And you can see a bit of a problem here,
which has occurred because basically we
have S and P 500 data for dates after
January, 2021 for the next two months.
But we don't have M2 data for that period.
So just to quickly resolve this, we're
just going to delete our S and P 500 price
data and our calculations in column D for
those two rows.
OK, so I'm just selecting those cells and
clearing the contents by pressing delete
on the keyboard.
OK, so as I said previously, we've left
some space at the top of the sheet here so
that we can do some analysis.
And we're going to include a chart and
also some percentile analysis.
And both of those are going to allow us to
kind of draw comparisons with M2 month on
month percentage change data and S and P
500 price data.
And we're going to start with a visual
assessment.
So we're going to start with the chart
first.
And we're going to basically plot S and P
500 data and our M2 month on month data
within the same chart to make it easy to
to kind of look at the data and compare it
over time.
So I'm clicking into cell B2 here and then
I'm going to go to insert on the ribbon
and insert a 2D line chart.
And I'm going to move that chart area
that's just appeared on the sheet into the
top of the sheet and then make the chart
area a bit bigger.
And as I said, we want to include both S
and P 500 prices and M2 month on month
data in this chart.
So what I'm going to do is right click
within this chart and go to select data
and add a series.
The first series that we're going to add
is the S and P 500 data.
The series name I'm just going to put
equal to the title that we see in cell C
24.
So S and P 500 and the series values.
I'm going to overwrite what's in this box
at the moment and select all of our S and
P 500 prices that we have from cell C 25
down to the last observation cell C 636
and then press OK.
Remember, we always want to include the
axis labels as well whenever we include a
series.
So these are going to be our dates.
I'm going to edit the horizontal axis
labels here and select all of our dates
starting from our first observation,
which is a 25 cell a 25 control shift and
down to select all of the dates down to
the bottom of the data set.
So down to a 636 and press OK and press OK
again.
When we scroll to the top of the sheet,
we'll see that we've got a nice line chart
of all of our S and P 500 prices.
Now what I'm going to do is add in our M
two month on month percentage growth
values into this same chart.
So I'm going to right click within the
chart, go to select data.
We're going to add a new series and this
series title is just going to be the text
that we see in cell D 24.
OK, M two month on month percentage growth
and the series values are just going to go
from D 25 control shift and down twice to
get to the end of the data set.
So down to D 636 and I press OK here and
then we're going to edit the horizontal
axis labels just as we did with the S and
P 500 prices.
So they're going to be our observation
dates and click on edit there and choose
all of the observation dates that we have
in this table as well.
Now, I just want to make sure here that
you guys understand why I chose the M two
month on month percentage growth data to
start from cell D 25 rather than D 26,
which is where our actual first
calculation was.
It's just basically so that Excel knows to
line up the correct data with the correct
rows.
So if we chose from cell D 26 and down,
then it would misalign those values with
our dates and our other S and P 500 data.
OK, so it's always best to make the series
length the same basically for every series
that you add to a chart.
OK, so you can see in our chart here
basically we've got S and P 500 price
data, which is the blue line.
We've got an axis which is configured to S
and P 500 prices and we've got our M two
month month percentage growth values.
Now this orange line represents the month
on month percentage growth values for M
two.
And you can see it's basically zero the
whole way across, which makes sense
because these values that we see in column
D are basically zero.
So how do we actually compare, you know,
the sort of trends and changes in M two
with S and P prices in a chart?
Well, we add these M two month on month
percentage change values to a secondary
axis.
So an axis that's going to be on the right
hand side of this chart.
And to do that, we can just click on that
line.
Double click on that line, I should say,
and then choose secondary axis from the
format data series panel that appears on
the right hand side.
And you'll see then that that data then
plots itself against a separate axis on
the right hand side of the chart.
And we can much more easily see changes
that are occurring in month on month
percentage change data for M two.
Okay.
There's definitely some aesthetic changes
that I think we should make to this chart.
So I'm going to go ahead and make a few
changes now.
But just remember that when I'm doing
this, whenever we're talking about the
aesthetics of charts, it's always down to
kind of your own personal taste.
So you don't necessarily have to follow
these steps that I'm going to go through
exactly.
You guys can just go ahead, play around
with the styles that you like to view
charts in and just create your own.
So the first thing that I want to do is
actually change this month on month line
data to column data.
Okay.
So to do that, I'm basically going to just
go to chart type with the chart selected.
So change chart type within the design tab
on the ribbon.
And then down here where it says chart
type and there's a dropdown menu next to M
two month on month growth.
I'm going to change this to a 2D column
chart.
And in a similar way to what I did with
the previous chart, I'm going to basically
color the positive values of this column
chart as green.
And the negative ones as red.
So to do that, we can just click on that
series and go to fill and line in the
format data series panel on the right hand
side.
And then choose solid color, solid fill
within the fill dropdown, the fill tab and
invert if negative.
And then we're going to choose our
positive and negative colors.
Okay.
So the positive color, I'm just going to
make dark green and the negative color.
I'm going to make red.
What I'm also going to do while I'm here
is reduce the gap width in the series
options tab here.
So I'm just going to make the columns
basically all appear right next to each
other with no gaps in between them.
It'd be very hard to notice with this data
anyway, but when you've got data that's
less compact, you know, there's less of
it.
And then you will you'll see this have
more of an effect.
So anyway, I'm going to change the gap
width to 0% there.
And next, what I want to do is change the
S&P chart, the S&P line.
Basically, there's a couple of things I
want to change here.
One, I want to make it a sort of thinner
black line.
And the second more important factor that
I want to change is the actual scale of
the axis.
And I'm going to make it into a
logarithmic scale.
OK, because that's going to allow us to
see basically kind of percentage changes
or percentage moves in S&P prices
historically more easily.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
Let's first change this line from this
thick blue line to a dark black line
that's thinner.
So I've just clicked on that line there
for S&P 500 prices.
And I'm going to go to fill and line on
the format data series panel on the right
hand side.
And then for the line, I'm going to choose
a solid line, make it black and also
change the width in this box here.
Just down a few points, we can make it one
point wide.
OK, so that just makes the line a little
bit clearer and a little bit more accurate
because it's thinner.
Now, let's go on to changing the scale, as
I mentioned before.
And the reason that I want to kind of show
you this is because when you're looking,
you know, just kind of eyeballing a
historical chart like this,
you can, you know, you're looking at the
S&P 500 from 1970 or maybe you've got data
before that as well.
Basically, when you look at this, you can
barely see any changes in the line
historically, you know, before, say, 1990,
because the price has moved, you know, so
much in absolute terms over that period.
Now, obviously, when you look at this and
you think about it in terms of
percentages, you know, month on month
percentages or year on year percentages
for the S&P 500,
it's not like it's moving hundreds of
percent now and it was only moving, you
know, 5% back then.
It was moving similar percentages with
similar volatility the whole way through
its history.
The reason why that doesn't show up is
because the absolute values have changed
so much.
So logarithmic scales kind of help us see
around this issue a little bit.
Basically, it just allows us to eyeball,
you know, changes in S&P 500 prices a
little bit more easily when we're dealing
with long historical series.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to
double click on the Y axis, so the S&P 500
Y axis, and then I'm going to go to Axis
Options.
And within this Axis Options tab in the
Format Axis panel, I'm going to choose a
logarithmic scale.
When I tick this box, it's going to
automatically scale this to base 10 and
you'll see what that means in a moment.
So when I click this box, you can see that
it's changed the price scale on the left
hand side to start at one.
Then it jumps to 10 to 100 to 1000 to
10,000.
So basically for every constant height in
the charts, it's split it into four
segments.
You can see into quarters. It's actually
multiplying the scale by a factor of 10.
Now that's a bit much for this chart.
Okay, we don't need to do that.
We don't need to use base 10 log for these
prices.
I think it shows up best with base 2.
So I'm going to change that value on the
right hand side to 2.
Press enter and you'll see what this does.
Okay, so now it's going 1, 2, 4, 8, 16.
So it's multiplying by 2 each time.
And then once we've done that, I'm going
to change the minimum bound for that axis
to 50.
Okay, and we'll leave the maximum on auto.
And then what you can see is we can really
kind of easily understand changes in the
S&P 500 over time by doing that.
Okay.
And it doesn't look as kind of skewed to
the latest data as it did before.
Okay, so the final changes that I want to
make to this chart is basically add a
legend for each series to kind of define
what each series is.
And then also add a Y axis title to both
the primary axis, primary Y axis and the
secondary Y axis as well.
So to do that, I'm clicking on the chart
area.
I'm going to go to the design tab on the
ribbon, add chart element.
We're going to start with the legend.
So I'm going to scroll down to this legend
option here and then just put a legend at
the top.
You'll see that that adds a legend for
defining, you know, which line is the S&P
500 data and which line is the M2 data.
Okay, so that just makes it clear for us.
I'm then going to add another chart
element.
This is going to be our axis titles.
It's going to be our primary vertical and
secondary vertical axis titles that we're
going to add.
So I'll do primary first.
And we're just going to rename this axis
S&P 500 prices and then add the other axis
title as well.
Secondary vertical axis title and rename
this to M2 month on month percentage
growth.
And actually, while I'm here, I've just
noticed that we should probably convert
this axis.
So our M2 growth values from decimals to
percentages.
So to do that, we can just click or select
that axis and then go to axis options.
So over here, axis options number and
choose category percentage to two decimal
places is fine.
That makes more sense.
Okay, so that will do for the chart.
I think basically what that does is just
give us a bit of a visual idea of when
large M2 month on month percentage changes
happened historically and how they
corresponded to market movements.
So what we can do now is formalize this a
little bit by finding out which months
exactly had abnormal M2 growth.
And the way we can do that is by filtering
the data that we have by percentiles and
percentiles are just the intervals that
represent the top 1, 2, 3, 4, 5% of data
and so on.
And we're only really concerned with the
highest percentiles since they represent
the most sort of abnormal positive prints
in M2.
So let's have a look at creating those in
another analysis table on this sheet.
So over in cell M2 here, I'm going to head
up this new analysis table.
I'm going to title it percentile analysis.
And in the cells below that, so from M3
downwards, I'm just going to write out all
the percentiles that we're going to
calculate for our M2 month on month
percentage change data.
Okay, so I know I said previously that
basically we're most concerned with our
abnormally positive data for M2 growth.
But I think in order to be comprehensive,
we're going to calculate percentiles that
are kind of abnormally low and, you know,
around the middle of the data as well,
because I think that will just help you in
general with conducting percentile
analysis going forward.
Okay, so I'm just going to write these out
now.
I'm going to start with the first
percentile.
We're going to do the lowest five
percentiles here.
And then I'm going to skip to the 10th
percentile, the 25th percentile.
So the lowest quarter of data, 50th
percentile.
That would essentially be the median of
the data, the middle of the data set.
Then the top quarter of data, the 75th
percentile.
The top 10% of data would be the 90th
And we obviously want to make sure we get
the abnormal prints on the positive side,
as I've been saying.
So we need to look at the top 5% of data
and so on.
So here I'm just listing out all of the
top kind of individual five percentiles of
data that we're going to that we're going
to find values for.
Now, to be clear about what percentile
analysis actually is, a percentile is the
value below which a percentage of the data
falls within a given data set.
OK, so if we're looking at M2 month on
month percentage growth as we are here, if
we want to understand what the first
percentile value is for that data set, we
want to know the value at which 1% of the
data falls below.
OK, and the same applies for all of this.
So if we look at the 99th percentile, we
want to know the value at which 99% of M2
growth data falls below.
OK, so the formula to work that out in
Excel is equals percentile dot INC.
And I'm writing this into cell N3 because
we're going to work this out for the first
percentile of data.
So it's equals percentile dot INC, open
brackets, then we're going to reference
the array or the data set that we want to
calculate this percentile for, which is
obviously going to be data we see in
column D, our M2 growth data.
So I'm just selecting column D for that
parameter and then going to put in a comma
to move on to the next parameter in the
function.
And you can see that's just called K and K
just refers to or K just means basically
the percentile that you want to calculate.
So what we're going to do here is just
click on the percentile we want to
calculate.
So that's in cell M3, the first
percentile, and then close the brackets
for that function and press enter.
Okay, so we have a value now and that
value represents the first percentile of
data, i.e. 1% of our M2 growth data falls
below this value.
And if I copy that down, we can see, you
know, that 99% of the data falls below
this value for M2 growth.
Now, before I move any further on, let's
change the formatting of these decimals to
percentages.
So I'm going to click and drag to select
over cell N3 to N17, all those values
we've just calculated.
Right click within that selection, go to
format cells, change the category to
percentage to three decimal places.
So this is a bit like what we did
previously, just displayed in a slightly
different way.
So rather than looking at somewhat
arbitrary histogram intervals and standard
deviations, we can look at exact
percentiles very quickly.
And what we're saying here, for example,
is that the top 5% of M2 monthly growth
values are above 1.2%.
And the top 1% of monthly M2 growth values
are above the value of 2.1%.
So that allows us to assess each monthly
value that comes out in terms of what
percentile of M2 growth it falls within.
So if the value is in the 95th percentile
or higher, we should probably be paying
attention to it and thinking about what
that means.
Does it mean the Fed's being reactive or
proactive?
Is it in line with what we're seeing in
other indicators?
Is the stimulus enough or is it too little
too late?
So let's have a look at some of these
abnormal moves now with some historical
context.
And what I'm going to do here is basically
filter our M2 data, our M2 growth data for
the top 2% of values.
And the way I'm going to do that is by
clicking on any one of our headings that
we have for our columns of data down here.
So I'm just going to click on cell D24,
our M2 growth data heading and then going
to data on the ribbon and choosing filter.
And then we want to select the filter
dropdown from our M2 growth data and then
go to number filters and choose greater
than.
And what we're going to do here is filter
all the values for our M2 month on month
growth so that it only shows values that
are greater than a certain number.
And that number is going to be whatever
the 98th percentile value is for our data.
So it's going to account for the top 2% of
our M2 growth values.
So that value is 1.387%.
Now in decimal format that would be
0.01387.
So I'm just going to type that in that box
there and we need to make sure obviously
that we're only showing rows where M2
month on month growth is greater than.
So make sure greater than is selected from
this dropdown.
And then we can press OK.
And what you'll see then is it returns all
the values or all the months where the M2
growth is in the top 2% of all values.
OK, so where it's above this 1.387%
cutoff.
Now, before I go into any more detail
about these values or these months in
particular, let's have a look at our
chart.
You can see that that's been disrupted
somewhat by filtering the data.
And at the moment that chart is just
trying to display the data that it sees in
these rows.
And so it's not basically displaying all
of the data that's hidden.
And we want to change that because we
don't really want our chart to be
disrupted just because we filter these
data series down here.
So I'm going to right click in the chart
and go to select data and then going to
choose this option down here called hidden
and empty cells.
And I'm then going to basically check this
checkbox down here that says show data in
hidden rows and columns and press OK.
And you can see then that all our data is
displayed despite some rows being hidden
because we've we've used the filter
options.
So back to our filter data. Now,
obviously, when you do this yourselves,
you can do this for more percentiles and
maybe you'll want to look at the top 5%
rather than the top 2%.
But I just want to give you an idea of the
sort of historical context that you might
find in these abnormal moves.
And you can see here that the filters
return just the top 2% of monthly M2
growth values and obviously the associated
dates that go with those.
And if we take a look through these dates,
you can see some pretty significant market
events for the most part where either the
Fed is responding to or preempting
liquidity issues.
So, for example, we've got September 2001
that was in response to the September 11th
terrorist attacks.
We've got December 2008.
That's obviously surrounding the global
financial crisis.
July and August 2011.
That's following the US credit downgrade.
We've got all of the values for 2020 and
2021 dates.
That's the sort of continuing provision of
liquidity for the COVID pandemic.
And then we've also got some some more
historical older events here that are a
little bit more structural in their
nature, such as in 1983, there was a
removal of interest rate ceilings that
meant basically a flood of money into
money market accounts.
That lifted M2.
And in 1971, there was massive inflation
generally partly partly due to a
relatively lax monetary policy that led to
wage and price freezes and the exiting of
the Bretton Woods agreement.
So it's really important to do some
digging and try to understand what's going
on at the time, you know, provide some
context to basically what the Fed is doing
with M2 growth.
Okay.
So we've been through our M2 analysis,
both on an individual basis and in the
context of historical
market events.
Hopefully you guys now have a good
understanding of how to do this analysis.
You know, why we do it and what to look
out for.
And that was obviously a very long
tutorial.
And realistically, this will take you
quite some time the first time you go
through the process.
The good news is that once you're
comfortable with how all of this works,
you can move on to using this automated M2
template file that I've created here for
you guys.
So let me just run through quickly how it
works now.
You can see it consists of two sheets that
are almost exactly the same as the ones
that I've just built in front of you in
this video.
The difference being is that these sheets
will automatically update their analysis
components whenever you enter new data
into the file.
So it's going to save you guys quite a lot
of time.
I'll start by explaining the nominal M2
monthly sheet.
The first thing to notice here is that
I've carried out the analysis for year on
year M2 data as well as month on month
data.
As I said, I was going to show you
earlier.
I've got month on month analysis data
running down the left hand side and year
on year analysis running down the right
hand side.
And in terms of the analysis components,
everything is the same here that we've
been through.
Apart from I've added some percentile
analysis at the bottom.
What I've done here for both month on
month and year on year data is displayed
the monthly and yearly growth values that
correspond to these various percentiles
that you can see.
And as we looked at before, this can give
you a much quicker and more accurate
picture of just how abnormal a certain
move in M2 growth is.
And to make things even easier, I've got a
cell here that returns the latest value
and the corresponding month for both month
on month and year on year M2 growth.
And also I've scored that value as a
percentage of all of the values in the
corresponding series.
So essentially this is a really, really
quick single number that tells you how
abnormal the most recent data is.
And you can see at the moment, the most
recent percent rank for month on month
data is 98.6%.
And year on year data is 100%.
So that's the highest it's ever been.
Now, when it comes to year on year data,
it's not responsive as month on month
data.
So in some ways it isn't as important when
it comes to spotting abnormal prints, as
we've discussed.
But what it does tell you is just how much
M2 growth that has been over a longer
period.
So a year.
And that gives you the idea of the sheer
size and more importantly, consistency of
liquidity that's being provided by the
Fed.
And the best way to kind of use this
analysis or use both month on month and
year on year data is by looking at them in
combination, as well as with or in the
context of other leading indicators.
That's how you're going to find it the
most useful.
So looking back at some of the analysis at
the top of the sheet, you'll see some
error values occurring, particularly on
the year on year side of the sheet.
Don't worry about these.
There's a reason that each one can't
return a value currently.
And I suggest that you just leave them as
is.
For example, the mode of year on year data
can't be computed because there is no
number that's been repeated.
So it can't detect what the most common
value is.
For our negative data analysis, there are
no negative year on year M2 growth prints
ever.
So obviously those cells will return an
error until we see some negative year on
year M2 values, if we ever do.
I'm not going to go through the formulas
in this template in any real detail
because it's outside the scope of this
video.
But just so you know, the way that
everything here is automated is through
the use of various different formulas,
which you can have a look at just by
clicking on the different analysis cells
in the sheet.
By all means, take a look at them,
backward engineer them.
If you're interested in learning how to
use Excel formulas for automating your own
spreadsheets, you're going to find some of
these really useful.
The final thing I want to cover briefly
are the steps that you need to take to
import new data into this template.
So for this nominal M2 monthly sheet, you
just need to download the new M2 data as I
showed you previously in the video and
copy all of the dates and all of the M2
values into columns A and B of this sheet.
And at that point, when you scroll to the
bottom of the sheet, you'll see that there
are month on month and year on year
calculation columns that need to be
updated as well.
So you can just update those by clicking
and dragging those formulas down as far as
necessary to keep up with the new data
that you've imported.
And once you've done that, all of the
analysis and charts will update
automatically.
If you want to update the historical
analysis sheet as well, you can.
The same principles apply here.
Make sure you remove the filter from the
columns of data that you already have and
copy and paste the new dates M2 and S&P
500 data into columns A, B and C in the
correct rows.
And then copy down the formulas that you
see in the M2 month on month column as
required.
You can also write some notes as I've done
here in column E when you go through the
exercise of assessing M2 in the context of
historical economic or market events.
You don't have to do that.
I just think it's useful sometimes to do a
bit of historical analysis and try and
understand the context of various
different M2 growth prints.
And that will give you a better, a better
frame of mind really for understanding M2
prints going forward as well.
Okay.
So well done guys.
That was a long video.
It was a lot to take in.
I know.
Go through the video and the accompanying
downloads as many times as it takes to get
this stuff to sink in.
Once you do, you're going to be in a great
position, both in your understanding of
the money supply, but also with your
knowledge of how to carry out this kind of
analysis in Excel,
whether it's for money supply or any other
data series that you want to look at in
this way.
So the key points I want to end on here
are firstly, if we look at M2 money supply
historically,
you'll see that there's a dynamic
relationship in terms of correlation with
the economy and markets in the past.
In the most recent few decades, M2 has
been used as a monetary stimulus policy to
provide liquidity.
And that's how it's still used currently.
And the Fed either uses this in a reactive
or a preemptive way when it sees either
actual or potential liquidity shocks.
To try and identify what significant M2
prints are, you're going to need to
convert the M2 money supply into monthly
percentage changes and calculate the
historic distribution of data series.
And then that gives you the context of
what kinds of values are historically
abnormal and therefore significant.
Abnormal prints can be identified in a
number of ways.
We use the histogram table and chart at
the beginning.
We also looked at standard deviations,
although remember when it came to M2
growth data, it's not exactly normal in
terms of its distribution.
And so using standard deviation requires
some careful consideration.
As well as those methods, we've also cut
right to the chase by using percentiles,
which help us identify what values
correspond to, for example, the top 1, 2,
3, 4 or 5% of data.
In the automated sheet, I've sped this
analysis up for you further by creating a
formula that returns the latest data and
its percent rank for you guys to assess as
soon as new data comes into the sheet.
Once you've identified or think you've
identified abnormal prints, you need to
think about those numbers in the context
of your knowledge that's been built up in
the course so far.
And also the knowledge that you're going
to learn in subsequent videos.
And you need to start asking yourself some
questions.
For example, does this M2 print value make
sense considering what money market
indicators and other leading indicators
are saying?
If it doesn't, why not?
What is the Fed seeing or what might the
Fed be seeing that I'm not?
Is the Fed being preemptive or reactive?
If it's being reactive, do we think the
stimulus is enough or it's too little too
late?
And I'm not saying you're going to have to
have concrete, 100% accurate answers to
these questions.
That's completely unrealistic.
They're very difficult to answer in some
circumstances.
But just by thinking about them is going
to lead you down the right track in terms
of thinking and understanding where
markets are currently and also where
they're heading.
So that's it for this video.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Well done again for getting through it.
Remember to go through this video and the
downloads as many times as you need to
understand it properly.
And don't worry if it takes time.
It's all just part of the process.
Remember, you're trying to build towards
conscious competence and you will get
there if you follow the series and
implement what you learn.
Good stuff, guys.
We'll finish there and I'll see you later
in the series.
Okay, so welcome back to the desk again.
So that was a very long video being over
three hours long.
But it's important to get on top of this
stuff.
Learn and utilize the method.
So the distribution of returns method and
analysis.
If you do that, you will give yourself the
ability to determine what is normal and
abnormal in asset prices and in economic
indicators.
So when it comes to M2 money supply, you
can understand Fed intentions and if
there's any read across into other areas
of the money market and read across into
the stock market.
So use the M2 money supply accessory on a
regular basis and in conjunction with
other money market indicators.
And we're going to be covering next in the
PTM video series.
Speaking of which, we're now going to move
away from the money market leading
indicators.
And we're now going to be looking at
surveys.
And there are lots of them.
We are going to be covering all of the
main macroeconomic surveys in the US and
overseas.
They are very important as a set of
indicators to add to your overall suite of
macro indicators and in helping us for our
macro view in the US and the rest of the
world.
So helping us to predict stock market
direction in the US and GDP growth
direction in the US and stock market
direction internationally and global GDP
growth direction internationally.
So we regularly stay on top of our surveys
and in conjunction with money market
indicators and cyclical commodity prices,
which we're going to look at later.
This will all form the basis of our
macroeconomic dashboard.
So let's start with one of the most
important macroeconomic surveys and we
will build up slowly and steadily to form
our macroeconomic dashboard.
Let's start with the ISM Manufacturing
Report on Business.
And I'll see you back at the desk in video
number eight.